Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Und hier in der 21. Ausgabe machen wir mal wieder ein neues Gesprächsfeld auf bei unserer Suche nach Ideen für das Lehren und das Lernen und genau das soll jetzt auch im Mittelpunkt stehen. Und zwar wollen wir uns einem besonderen Aspekt widmen, nämlich dem Aspekt des Spielens. Und in welcher Form wir das Ganze angehen werden, werde ich gleich erläutern, begrüße aber erst mal unseren Gast Linda Breitlauch, hallo schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, grüß dich.
Ja, ich bin jetzt hier gerade in Trier, an der Hochschule – wie heißt die korrekt vollständig ausgeschrieben?
Hochschule Trier und du bist hier im Fachbereich Gestaltung.
Fachbereich Gestaltung. Und du bist hier Professorin an einem Lehrstuhl für Gamedesign.
Intermedia Games das ist hier im Studiengang Intermedia-Design.
Und den gibt es aber auch noch nicht so lange?
Den gibt es seit ein paar Jahren schon und im Grunde genommen referenziert der so eben die Weiterentwicklung von Mediengestaltung, wie man das so kennt, klassische Mediengestaltung, Kommunikationsdesign usw. im Hinblick eben auf neue Medien. Also beginnt sozusagen mit allem, was das Internet an Erfordernissen gebracht hat, bis eben zu den ganzen Bereichen transmedialer Gestaltung im Umfeld von eben Computerspielen, Virtual Reality usw. Das sind so die Aspekte, mit denen wir uns in unterschiedlichen Lehrstühlen beschäftigen. Medienräume beispielsweise oder eben Hypermedia Games und noch so einige andere, die wir dann versuchen, mit abzudecken. Interdisziplinär in Kooperation mit den anderen Studiengängen, die wir hier eben haben, zum Beispiel der Informatik, die ja hier ein recht großer Studiengang ist und wo auch Spieleprogrammierung als Studiengang explizit angeboten wird. Und tatsächlich auch einer der größten in ganz Deutschland ist, so mit 600 Studierenden.
600 Studierende, die sich nur mit Spieleprogrammierung zentral auseinandersetzen?
Hier in Trier …
Kaum zu glauben.
In dem kleinen Trier so viele Programmierer.
Sind ja schon alle weg von der Straße.
Ja tatsächlich sind die auch hart umworben, gar keine Frage. Aber es weiß tatsächlich kaum einer in Deutschland, dass wir hier so einen großen Studiengang im Bereich Spieleprogrammierung haben. Wir sind im Vergleich jetzt hier auf der Designseite etwas kleiner, also wir sind künstlerisch wissenschaftlicher Studiengang und haben entsprechend auch Eignungsprüfungen, so dass wir etwas kleiner sind als Studiengang, mit etwas weniger Studierenden. Aber kooperieren trotzdem natürlich mit der Informatik und das ist ganz klar, man kann ja im Grunde genommen Spieleentwicklung eigentlich kaum noch alleine stemmen. Man macht das in der Regel in großen Teams oder von mir aus auch in kleineren Teams. Und daraus haben sich hier auch tatsächlich schon einige Unternehmen rauskristallisiert, Startups, die schon so bei ihren zweiten, dritten Spielen sind und jetzt versuchen, sozusagen sich zu professionalisieren auf dem Markt. Und ja wir wollen eigentlich, dass diese Entwicklung sich noch weiter entwickelt.
Möchten auch ganz gerne natürlich, dass sich hier auch mehr ansiedeln. Rheinland-Pfalz ist noch nicht so unbedingt Spieleentwicklerland, auch wenn es schon ein paar interessante Unternehmen gibt, aber wir sehen da noch ein großes Potenzial.
Mir würde das nochmal interessieren, also wie hier die Studiengänge zusammenarbeiten. Weil das ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt normal, dass das Ganze Studiengang- oder auch lehrstuhlübergreifend angegangen wird. Oft findet man ja sehr stark voneinander separierte Studiengänge, die dann mehr oder weniger gut zusammenarbeiten. Wie weit ist das hier gedacht? Also Informatik spielt eine Rolle, aber die anderen Bereiche, die du genannt hast, was muss man da noch mit aufzählen?
Also wir hatten natürlich grad zum Beispiel im Gestaltung haben wir irgendwie sieben unterschiedliche Studienrichtungen, Architektur beispielsweise, Kommunikationsdesign, Modedesign und so weiter. Was Intermedia Design ausmacht ist grundsätzlich erst mal diese Auffassung, zu sagen, also wir können nicht alles alleine abdecken und wir wollen den Studierenden auch die Möglichkeit geben, zum Beispiel über Wahlpflichtfächer nach ihrer Grundlagenausbildung sich selbst auszudifferenzieren, sich selbst ein eigenes Profil zu machen. Tolle Projekte zu machen, die vielleicht eben auch ein bisschen um die Ecke gedacht sind, ungewöhnlich und mit Studierenden zusammen, die aus einer anderen Richtung kommen. Und das funktioniert eben nur, wenn man sich wirklich interdisziplinär sowohl in diesem Fachbereich als aber auch insgesamt zur Hochschule und von mir aus natürlich auch noch darüber hinaus mit der Universität – da gibt es das eine oder Projekt – und so weiter, sich sozusagen dann entsprechend die Leute zusammensucht, die ihren Schwerpunkt in einem bestimmten Projekt realisieren möchten. Und der dann aber auch vielleicht mal ein bisschen anders gestrickt ist, als man das so üblicherweise kennt.
Also sprich wir gehen hier nicht so vor, dass wir sagen, in jedem Semester musst du ein ganz bestimmtes Projekt umsetzen und das ist curricular schon verankert und die Projektanforderung ist XY, programmier was weiß ich Pacman nach oder so was. Sondern die sollen sich tatsächlich zu eigenen Projekten finden und die dürfen ebne auch mal ganz anders sein. Also sie müssen zum Beispiel keine Spieleprojekte sein, von denen man immer ausgehen muss, dass sie möglicherweise anfangen zu kommerzialisieren, sie dürfen auch einen künstlerischen Aspekt haben oder auch komplett andere Ansätze. Die nicht notwendigerweise wirklich später auch auf dem Markt bestehen würden oder müssten, aber die eben ganz viele Möglichkeiten bieten, dass hier jeder Student sich hier ausprobieren kann und auch mal was anderes probieren kann, als was er dann später in der Branche machen. Weil da sind die Vorgaben doch relativ streng und ein Studium finde ich sollte vor allen Dingen dafür da sein, vor allen Dingen in den künstlerischen Bereichen dafür da sein, auch mal Dinge auszuprobieren und keine Angst vorm Scheitern zu haben.
Weil Scheitern eben, na wenn man so will, Lernmethode auch dazu gehört. Und das fördern wir natürlich auch. Also nicht das Scheitern, aber das ist eben nicht schlimm, nicht in diesem Kontext, aber die möglich …
Ist doch mit Christoph Schlingensief, Scheitern als Chance.
Genau, Scheitern als Chance, das ist auch tatsächlich so. Scheitern heißt ja nicht unbedingt, dass Projekte scheitern, sondern dass bestimmte Dinge einfach mal nicht funktionieren und dass man dann andere Wege der Problemlösung finden muss. Und dass man sich ständig mit Herausforderungen beschäftigen muss, die neu sind, weil man sie eben zum ersten Mal so denkt und so in der Form noch nicht umgesetzt hat. Und da wir hier ja in jedem Semester im Prinzip ein Projekt haben, auch Projekte haben, die über mehrere Semester laufen, und auch durchaus mit unterschiedlichen Teamzusammensetzungen, entwickeln sich da wirklich interessante Dynamiken und das was wir hier häufig zurückgespielt bekommen ist, ja das sind unglaubliche Lernprozesse, sowohl was so Teamdynamiken angeht, als aber auch fachlicher Art, wenn man selbst sozusagen selbst in der Verantwortung steht, das Projekt auch zum Erfolg zu bringen.
Was ich noch nicht ganz verstanden habe, also die Studenten, die du jetzt konkret in deinem Lehrstuhl betreust, welche Studiengänge verfolgen die? Ist das jetzt quer verteilt oder gibt es da nochmal einen separaten Studiengang, den man sich dann spezialisiert?
Also der Studiengang, in dem ich tätig bin, das ist Intermedia Design und der hat eben unterschiedliche Ausrichtungen, aber trotzdem sind alle Lehrgebiete für die Designer abgedeckt. Das heißt die müssen natürlich die Grundlagenmodule alle belegen, können sich dann aber später ausdifferenzieren und tatsächlich wenn sie das möchten oder sehen sich auch an andere Studiengänge orientieren. Die Kooperation, von der ich eben gesprochen habe, mit der Informatik, insbesondere der Spieleprogrammierung dort, das ist tatsächlich eine aktiv gelebte Zusammenarbeit zwischen mir sozusagen als Vertretung für Games und den Kollegen in der Informatik, wo wir wirklich gesagt haben, - weil das muss man in der Hochschule auch erst mal organisieren, dass wir wirklich Kurse zusammen machen können, die dann auch am selben Tag stattfinden, sonst ist es ja relativ sinnfrei, die dann auch gemeinsam bewertet werden können und so weiter – und an einer Hochschule gibt es viele Fachrichtungen und Studiengänge, die aber eben häufig anders strukturiert sind.
So dass natürlich die Organisationsaufgaben, die Herausforderungen an die Organisation sind schon nicht banal, das muss man schon sagen, aber wenn man das aktiv betreibt und lebt, dann geht das natürlich.
Jetzt würde mich natürlich mal interessieren, wie du überhaupt auf das Feld gekommen ist. Also weiß nicht, womit fing denn das an?
Mit Space Invaders.
Genau, womit hast du deine Jugend verschwendet? Mit Space Invaders?
Ja nicht meine ganze Jugend nein.
Nur die halbe.
Ja tatsächlich ist das so eine lustige Geschichte, immer wenn ich die Space Invaders auf der Originalkonsole, dann fällt mir das immer wieder ein, als ich 12-13 war, wir waren immer in Frankreich im Urlaub und dort haben die in den Sommerurlauben immer wirklich diese Arkaden aufgebaut, also auch zum Beispiel auf offenem Gelände usw. und das war so die erste Begegnung mit den Arkade-Konsolen der 80er Jahre.
Also die Arkaden sozusagen die Spielehöllen, Spielehallen.
Genau, richtige Höllen sozusagen.
In der ersten Zeit genau.
Und die hatten ja auch noch was von dem Spielhallenflair.
Heute ist das ja nur noch so ein Begriff, und man weiß ja gar nicht, wo es herkommt. Dass es tatsächlich eben die arkadenförmigen frühen Shoppingmalls in den USA waren.
Man weiß ja eigentlich schon, wo es herkommt. Genau aus den USA. Das war schon lang vor der Zeit, wo es Spielautomaten gab.
Wo Pinballs noch Pinballs. Eine kleine Kugel durch so Nagelbretter runterfiel.
Richtig, das waren dann so diese kleinen Ablenkungsgeschichten, die dann irgendwie in den Einkaufsszenen, wo man dann hier eine Kleinigkeit Mittagessen und da dann eben mal noch so ein Flipperspiel oder was auch immer anspielen konnte für einen Penny, um dann seine Mittagspause, seine viel zu kurze, da zu verbringen. Und daraus hat sich das dann halt irgendwann entwickelt. Dass man dann die 80er Jahre sozusagen Arkadezeit heute dafür steht, eigentlich nur für Spielhallen, aber entwickelt hat sich das ja eigentlich tatsächlich aus was ganz anderem.
Genau und dann hat es sich mit den frühen Heimcomputern…
Erledigt.
... so in den 70/80er oder im Prinzip überhaupt erst mal so elektronisiert und damit natürlich auch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise popularisiert, weil man musste nicht mehr zur Arkade gehen, sondern die Arkade kam sozusagen zu einem nach Hause. Und was stand dann irgendwie auf dem Tisch irgendwann?
Ja bei mir war es ein Commodore, den gibt es auch tatsächlich noch.
64 nehme ich an?
Natürlich. Also die Frage war ja, wie bin ich darauf gekommen? Also natürlich habe ich auch gespielt, aber ich bin offen gestanden lange Zeit nicht auf die Idee gekommen, über so was nachzudenken, wie kann man das denn studieren? Also da war ich übrigens nicht die einzige, ich glaube so die erste Generation Spieleentwickler in Deutschland hat sich diese Gedanken nicht gemacht, wenn überhaupt über die Informatik. Gibt ja viele Quereinsteiger.
Um nochmal da kurz zu bleiben. Also du hast schon viel gespielt? Also Spiele waren schon ein wichtiger Teil des Lebens früh?
Ja.
Was für Spiele?
Das hat sich verändert. Also am Anfang waren es tatsächlich so die üblichen Arkadespiele, aber später dann eher so über Textadventures, Grafikadventures und zwischenzeitlich hatte ich auch mal durchaus so eine Pause, wo im Grunde genommen, das war so nach dem Zusammenbruch der Arkadezeit und wo man erst mal neu sozusagen wieder Anlauf genommen hat.
So Ende der 80er Jahre.
Genau. Und sich dann auf andere Sachen konzentriert hat. Ich bin aber tatsächlich so Storytelling war irgendwie immer schon so meins. Wollte immer schon mal irgendwas in diese Richtung machen und bin dann sozusagen über diesen Weg so an das Interactive Storytelling gekommen und fand das auch immer eine unglaubliche Herausforderung. Ich habe ja an der Filmhochschule Dramaturgie und Drehbuchschreiben studiert und in diesem Kontext habe ich dann wieder Leute kennengelernt, die in der Spieleentwicklung tätig waren und wo wir dann uns getroffen hatten und gesagt haben, Mensch wie können wir da einen Dialog bauen hier in dem Spiel usw. Und über diesen Weg bin ich dann eigentlich erst darauf gekommen, Mensch das wäre ja tatsächlich auch eine Möglichkeit gewesen, das zu studieren, ach es gibt ja gar kein Studiengang stimmt.
Weil ich komme nicht aus der Informatikrichtung, sondern eher aus der Storytelling Gestalterrichtung und da gibt es ja auch erst seit man kann sagen 2007 oder so was Studiengänge in Deutschland, die auch explizit Gamedesign im Vordergrund haben. Und vorher gab es eben nur die Möglichkeit, wirklich über Informatik oder eben über einen Quereinstieg sich hier weiterzubilden. Und das ist mir tatsächlich schon vorher begegnet, weil ich habe ja auch schon in Brandenburg an der Hochschule im Fachbereich Informatik einiges gemacht und das hat mich immer schon begleitet. Aber tatsächlich zu sagen, kann man das eigentlich auch studieren den Bereich Gamedesign, das ist ja bis heute noch vielen nicht bekannt, dass das tatsächlich möglich ist, weil das eben einfach noch nicht so lange existiert.
Ich grübel jetzt auch gerade. Ich meine, da muss man mal jetzt so ein bisschen auch die Geschichte nochmal bedienen. Wir hatten ja die 80er Jahre, da kam das halt mit diesen frühen Spiele.. - also jetzt schon in den 70er Jahren – Spielekonsolen und man konnte so Pong spielen, so diese festverdrahteten Geschichten. Dann kamen halt die Homecomputer, der C64 Atari etc. die ersten Konsolen, die ja dieses Spieleerlebnis sehr viel bunter gestaltet haben, in die Zimmer gebracht haben. Man musste halt keinen Penny mehr einschmeißen, dadurch hat das natürlich eine ganz andere Verbreitung gefunden. Meine Wahrnehmung der Spiele der damaligen Zeit war, dass das eben vor allem Leute waren, also die Spiele, die einen besonders beeindruckt haben, waren dann immer so von Leuten gemacht, die haben halt alles gemacht. Die haben halt das programmiert, die haben sich das Spiel ausgedacht, die haben es gestaltet, je nachdem wie die eigenen Fähigkeiten so waren. Aber sehr lange waren Spiele immer so Einzelkämpferergebnisse.
Richtig ja.
Irgendwann hat sich das dann so ein bisschen diversifiziert, weil natürlich auch die Herausforderung immer komplexer wurde. Man musste halt programmieren, es sollte halt schön sein. Also Leute müssen sich da sozusagen mehr reinarbeiten. Wann hat sich das so aufgespalten, dass man wirklich jetzt sagen kann, okay jetzt gibt es hier einen designerischen Teil und einen Codingteil und ein Sounddesign.
Also klar, und Pong konnte noch von Allan Alcorn mehr oder weniger alleine innerhalb von einem Monat umgesetzt werden, ich glaube es war ein Monat. Das lag natürlich daran, dass die Grafik einfach nicht mehr drauf hatte und dass der Sound noch mit ein paar Tönen auskam und deswegen musste das über das Gameplay funktionieren. Und das ist, wenn man es sich genauer anschaut, ein ganz großartiges Gameplay. Und mit den technischen Möglichkeiten stieg dann immer auch die Anforderung sozusagen an die bessere Umsetzung, was nicht immer bedeutet hat, dass das Spiel deswegen besser geworden wäre, sondern vielleicht schöner oder erzählender oder was auch immer. Also es ist schon interessant, dass eigentlich Geschichten, interaktive Geschichten sozusagen von Anfang an da waren, eigentlich in den 70er Jahren schon. Und letzten Endes die Gameplay-Mechaniken, die wir heute haben, die mögen vielleicht insgesamt deutlich komplexer geworden sein, oder die Art und Weise wie man interagiert, auf welchen Ebenen man interagiert mit einem Spiel ist sicherlich in vielen Spielen komplexer geworden. Trotzdem sind die Mechaniken eigentlich kaum verändert.
Wie sind denn diese Mechaniken?
Naja die Mechaniken sind im Grunde genommen, wenn man es sich genauer anschaut, auf ein paar wenige zu reduzieren. Die Frage ist halt nun mal, wie setzt man sie dann tatsächlich im Interface zum Beispiel um oder in der Steuerung um oder so was.
Also Beispiele, was sind jetzt so die klassischen Mechaniken?
Was ist die Pong-Mechanik? Es ist einfach ein relativ simples Hand-Augen-Koordinationsspiel, wo ich also mit dem Joystick versuchen muss, immer an der rechten Stelle zu sein, wenn ich reagieren muss. Also diese Mechaniken die finden wir heute alle in den Mobile Games oder in vielen Mobile Games eben wieder. Die ganzen Arkadespiele, die eigentlich auch nur so 2-3 kleine Mechaniken hatten, und natürlich immer auf Zeit gepolt waren. Also ganz klar, ich schmeiße eine Münze ein und dann habe ich eine bestimmte Spielzeit und so verdient das Spiel Geld. Und diese Mechaniken die finden wir heute alle wieder in den Mobile Games.
Stimmt bis hin zu 1:1 Kopien der alten Spiele.
Breakout beispielsweise. Hunderte Male kopiert und geändert worden usw.
Frogger.
Frogger. Ja was weiß ich. Die Mechanik von Angry Bird oder welche auch immer du nimmst, es sind im Prinzip …
Stimmt. Und damals dachte man irgendwie so, jetzt ist das alles vorbei und weg und das kommt nie wieder. Und tatsächlich kommt es auf breiter Front wieder.
Richtig und es kommt interessanterweise eben auf dem Mobile Markt, aber nicht, also natürlich auch mit dem Monetarisierungsgedanken dahinter. Also man steigert den Schwierigkeitsgrad und dann verliert man seine fünf Leben und dann kann man sich entweder neue kaufen oder muss ein paar Stunden warten. Dazwischen haben wir natürlich noch sozusagen diese Facebook-Ära, die so Spiele wie Farmville oder so was mit groß gemacht haben und die einfach verstanden haben, dass dieses Free to Play Konzept eine Möglichkeit ist, um zu monetarisieren, insbesondere in diesem – jetzt würde ich es tatsächlich so nennen – Casual Games Bereich. Denn de facto sind Arkadegames von der Mechanik, du kannst eigentlich nicht gewinnen, es ist immer so das Spiel gegen das Ende. Das heißt du hast immer eine kurze Spielzeit, aber ein einfaches Spielprinzip, was immer wiederholbar ist und was du auch sofort verstehst, und das kannst du dann natürlich noch variieren und musst es natürlich auch, um einen Wiederspielwert zu haben. Und diese Mechanik ist nicht nur bis heute erhalten geblieben beziehungsweise hat sich natürlich an diesem Free to Play Konzept auch noch entsprechend abgearbeitet.
Sondern ist glaube ich noch mit dafür verantwortlich, dass man die Zielgruppe der Gamer nochmal erhöht hat. Weil jeder hat irgendein Smartphone oder was auch immer, du hast also eine viel höhere Reichweite, als damals wo du noch zu den Geräten gehen musstest. Also da ist eine extrem hohe Reichweite, quasi ja jeder, der ein Smartphone oder sonst irgendein mobiles Gerät hat. Und du hast die Chance, Menschen sozusagen dann zum Spielen zu bringen, wenn sie nicht viel Zeit haben. Morgens im Bus, mittags in der Pause oder was auch immer.
Ich finde man könnte auch sagen, dass Spielen an sich jetzt ein echter Volkssport geworden ist. Also ich meine, alle Leute, die jetzt ein Casual Game spielen als Gamer zu klassifizieren, da greift ja dieser Begriff irgendwie nicht mehr. Ich meine Gamer sind zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung Leute, die halt mehr oder weniger obsessiv, also zumindest mit sehr viel Zeitaufwand sich dem Spiel widmen, extrem komplexe tiefe lange Spiele spielen, was ja die allermeisten ja halt so nicht tun.
Das ist im Moment eine ganz heftig geführte Diskussion innerhalb der Gamercommunity. Also man unterteilt ja inzwischen tatsächlich die Spieler in alle möglichen Zielgruppen. Man spricht von Hardcoregamern und von Casualgamern, da gibt es die Hardcorecasualgamer und so weiter und so weiter. Und dann gibt es eben auch immer die, die sagen, also jemand, der nur Candy Crush spielt kann kein Gamer sein. Wo man dann sagt, ja okay, wer sagt das? Also das sagen ja dann die, die kein …
Kein Candy Crush können.
... kein Candy Crush spielen wollen und das kann ich auch gut nachvollziehen. Aber die dann sozusagen auch sagen, nein das ist sozusagen unser eigenes, unser Kulturgut und das ist aber trotzdem insofern – also das ist einerseits eine spannende Diskussion, weil es eben eine Diskussion ist, die genauso auch schon in anderen Medien geführt wurden, wenn es um Arthouse-Filme geht, dass man sich dann durchaus auch differenziert von denen, die dann irgendwie nur den Tatort gucken oder so was. Das heißt na klar gibt es sicher eine unterschiedliche, wertfrei könnte man ja sagen, Zielgruppe, aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Mentalitäten. Also wenn ich Monate, Jahre lang Eve spiele, um ein einigermaßen guter Eve-Spieler zu werden, ich glaube dafür braucht man schon ein paar Jahre.
Eve ist?
Eve Online, also im Grunde genommen das komplexeste und vom Schwierigkeitsgrad her umfassendste MMO, was es wohl derzeit gibt. Man spielt da eben ein Raumschiff und du hast so irrsinnig viele Möglichkeiten, dich auszuskillen und du brauchst eigentlich echt ein Betriebswirtschaftsstudium, um überhaupt mit diesen ganzen ausdifferenzierten Wirtschaftsabläufen und so weiter und so weiter dich auszukennen. Ich meine ein Satz, den sicher jeder kennt, ist, als ich gemerkt habe, dass die Tabellen für WOW, setze beliebiges anderes MMO ein, größer waren als die für mein eigenes Unternehmen, habe ich auch aufgehört zu spielen. Das kann ich total nachvollziehen, dass man einfach anfängt, wirklich taktisch strategisch vorzugehen und wirklich Zeit und Arbeit investiert und auch wirklich richtig was rein gibt. Also auch in die Community was rein gibt.
Und dann verglichen zu werden sozusagen mit irgendeinem, der nur Candy Crush spielt, dass das nicht so richtig zusammenpasst, das ist irgendwie auch klar. Das heißt es hat mit der ernsthaften Auseinandersetzung mit einem Spielsystem zu tun oder auch mit vielen Spielsystemen, es gibt ja auch genug Leute, die das in WOW machen, die Gilden führen und die dann eine richtige soziale Verantwortung drin sehen und so weiter. Die also sämtliche Mechaniken kennen, die wissen, welcher Rubin für welche Klasse an welcher Stelle richtig gesetzt sein muss und so weiter. Dass das jetzt nicht vergleichbar ist mit dem Aufwand, den man mit einem Casual Game betreibt, mit irgendeinem Farmville, wo man drei mal am Tag draufklickt, das ist ja ganz klar. Trotzdem ist diese Wertediskussion letzten Endes naja eigentlich nicht so wirklich notwendig. Im Sinne von, es tut ja keinem weh. Wenn irgendjemand sagt, ich verstehe mich als Spieler, was soll es.
Also wenn ich ein Buch lese einmal im Monat einen Comic oder wenn ich alle Thomas Mann Bücher in einer Woche lese, kann man diesen Unterschied aufmachen, die Frage ist nur, wem nützt das? Das ist sicher eine Kulturdiskussion und die ist auch spannend zu führen, aber es wird niemals so etwas wie eine Auflösung dazu geben.
Ganz unabhängig davon, wie man die Leute nennt oder wie sie sich selber nennen, kann man glaube ich schon unterscheiden, es gibt viele Leute, die das Spiel als mehr begreifen als nur einen Zeitvertreib. Was sicherlich für dieses Casualgaming irgendwie gilt. Das ist so zum Abschalten. Da taucht man mal kurz ab und kann irgendwie dabei über Sachen nachdenken, weil man sich mit dem Spiel selber eigentlich gar nicht groß auseinandersetzen muss. Auf der anderen Seite hat man dann eben so Extreme. Wie zum Beispiel diese Online Games, diese Multi-User unglaublich tiefe Welten Spiele, in denen man halt extrem viel lernen muss, um überhaupt das Spiel richtig spielen zu können. Also die Bereitschaft, das eigene Hirn überhaupt sich damit auseinandersetzen zu lassen, die muss ja sehr sehr groß sein, aber dann lernt man eben zwangsläufig eben diese Mechaniken in diesem Spiel und dann ist ja eigentlich ein intensiver …
Es sind nicht nur die Mechaniken, die sind vielleicht nicht immer das herausfordernde. Sicher bei manchen Spielegenres schon, sind aber auch bei denen, wo es wirklich, die auch sich für E-Sports zum Beispiel eignen, da geht es um die Beherrschung der Mechanik, aber um wirklich das Spielsystem, ein komplexes Spielsystem auch zu verstehen und strategisch und taktisch zum Beispiel zu beherrschen. Und dann vielleicht noch mit der Komponente, Communitys zu betreuen, also zum Beispiel eine eigene Gilde zu führen oder so was, da wird ja noch viel viel mehr gefordert, als nur eine Mechanik zu beherrschen. Also „nur“, weil es natürlich auch in der Regel, also bei den MMO, die wir jetzt so angesprochen haben, geht es natürlich auch um die Beherrschung einer immer komplexer werdenden Mechanik, aber eher in Form von Prozessen und Abläufen, als nur in Form von, dass ich ein paar Steuerungselemente bedienen kann. Und vielleicht noch in der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Sondern da geht es ja um noch viel mehr als das. Und das ist tatsächlich zum Teil Jahre lang, wenn man so will, Arbeit. Also man muss sich auch teilweise Jahre lang damit beschäftigen. Wenn du dir anschaust, also ein berühmteres bekanntes Beispiel ist eben World of Warcraft. Inzwischen ist es ja, was die Community ja selber zum Teil nicht gut findet, casualisiert. Viel einfacher geworden als am Anfang. Wenn man den Startscreen sieht, wenn man ganz neu anfängt, da sind da irgendwie 3-4 kleine Fensterchen, da ist ein bisschen Inventar, da ist ein bisschen dies und das. Wenn man einen Screen von einem Spieler sieht, der schon 500 Stunden gespielt hat, dann ist das Spiel ja kaum noch wieder zu erkennen. Das ist komplett zugelagert mit Interfaces, mit Anzeigen, mit AddOns, mit was auch immer. Was man dann alles gleichzeitig beherrschen muss. Und wer mal jemals auf so einer E-Sport-Veranstaltung, wenn dann zum Beispiel Warcraft oder was auch immer gespielt wird, das ist eine unglaubliche Geschwindigkeit, in der man diese Abläufe ausführen, aber vor allem auch beherrschen muss, also was hat das für Konsequenzen.
Es geht ja nicht irgendwie um einen Cookie-Clicker, in dem man nur besonders schnell irgendwas klicken kann. Sondern das Ganze sozusagen wie man interagiert über das Gameplay auch noch einzuordnen in die richtige Taktik und Strategie, um entweder mit seinem Team oder alleine oder wie auch immer voranzukommen.
Jeder Spieler ein eigenes Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum sozusagen.
Ja. Im Grunde genommen ja.
Weil ja extrem viel Komplexität, die man sich visualisieren muss, die man irgendwie vollständig durchdrungen haben muss, um dann in Echtzeit auf alle möglichen Ereignisse reagieren zu können und die richtigen Maßnahmen zu ergreifen. Also ich meine nichts anderes macht ein Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum. Und ja die Bildschirme sehen ja auch nicht so sehr viel anders aus.
Man erkennt ja kaum noch das Spielfeld und es geht letzten Endes auch gar nicht mehr darum. Es gibt ja Szenarien, Dungeons, wenn ich in eine Ini gehe mit 40 Leuten, dann mache ich die ja nicht einmal und dann ist gut, sondern ich mache sie ja immer und immer wieder auf allen möglichen Schwierigkeitsherausforderungen. Also am liebsten dann nachher auf Hero, also sprich auf heldenhaft, das ist dann halt besonders schwierig und so weiter. Aber das Spielfeld erkenne ich schon noch, da hinten ist Boss 1, Boss 2 und so weiter, aber es geht nicht mehr darum, dass es toll aussieht oder so was, sondern es geht darum, dass es performant ist, dass alle 40 Leute gleichzeitig sehen können, was passiert. Dass du alle Anzeigen im Blick hast. Und es ist wirklich gar nicht so weit weg von einem Kontrollzentrum. Und gleichzeitig dabei kommunizieren mit allen anderen.
Ist ja so ein klassischer Vorwurf damals wie heute, dass Leute, die sich halt so intensiv mit solchen Spielesystemen auseinandersetzen und da sich drin verlieren, wie man so schön sagt, ja dann mit der Realität nichts mehr zu tun haben, nur noch von dem Spiel aufgesogen werden. Ich denke, wenn man selber aktiv spielt und wir haben jetzt auch schon einiges davon anklingen lassen, dann wird einem schnell klar, dass das jetzt alles so fern der Realität dann auch wieder nicht ist. Weil am Ende sind natürlich auch sämtliche Szenarien, die man durchspielen muss, sämtliche Strategien, die man dort entwickeln muss, um Lösungen zu finden, sind ja echte Lerneffekte, die im Prinzip auch im richtigen Leben eine Rolle spielen können. Also das was man dabei erlernt ist das auch wertvoll für Dinge jenseits des Spiels?
Also Realität ist ja so ein Begriff, der immer gerne mit Wirklichkeit gleichgesetzt wird, was aber eigentlich gar nicht stimmt. Realität ist ja nur das, was wir wahrnehmen von der Wirklichkeit und es gibt nicht ohne Grund den Begriff virtuelle Realität. Was im virtuellen Raum passiert, kann für mich in meiner Realität ja genauso wirklich sein, wie eine objektive Wirklichkeit, der Tisch, der in diesem Raum steht. Also das ist immer so ein bisschen die Diskussion, die man führen kann und will, ist das sozusagen alles was im virtuellen Raum passiert, das ist ja alles irgendwie nicht real, sagt man immer so gerne. Das ist natürlich Unsinn. Aber das heißt, kann man aus Spielen etwas lernen? Das ist eigentlich nicht wirklich die Frage, denn Spiele oder das Spielen an sich ist ja sozusagen eine der ersten und wichtigsten und effektivsten Lernformen, die es überhaupt gibt.
Man weiß das aus der Pädagogik schon lange, es bestreitet ja auch gar keiner. Was man nur bestreitet ist, können Computerspiele, die eben sozusagen auf dem Bildschirm stattfinden und mir ein Tor geben zu einer wie auch immer gearteten virtuellen Welt, können die sozusagen das was das Spiel an positiven Effekten hat ebenfalls abbilden oder ist es nicht eher das Gegenteil davon? Da muss man sich natürlich erst mal die Frage stellen, nur weil es auf einem Bildschirm stattfindet ist es deswegen schlechter als andere Spielprinzipien? Ist sicher zu diskutieren, keine Frage. Man spricht ja also irgendwie von haptischem Erleben und so weiter. Das Spielprinzip an sich ist auf jeden Fall erst mal die Möglichkeit, sehr effektiv zu lernen, weil es immer in einem geschützten Raum stattfindet. Das heißt ich habe im Prinzip in dem Moment, wo ich im Spiel gewinne oder verliere, zwar etwas erlebt und gelernt, aber es ist erst mal noch nicht in der Wirklichkeit relevant. Also es hat noch keine Konsequenzen in der Wirklichkeit.
Und das bedeutet im Grunde genommen, dass das Spiel deswegen einer der besten Lernformen sein muss, weil ich so lange probieren kann nach meinem eigenen Rhythmus, deswegen spricht man da immer von dem Aspekt der Probehandlung, bis ich tatsächlich in einem bestimmten Punkt oder irgendwelchen Dingen so gut geworden bin, dass der Lernprozess als abgeschlossen angesehen werden kann, im Hinblick auf bestimmte Dinge. Und tatsächlich ist es beim Spiel so, ich kann selbst wenn ich sehr viel Zeit mit einem Spiel verbringe, wird es immer irgendwann einen Punkt geben, wo ich sage, ich habe alles gemacht in diesem Spiel, ich bin der beste und jetzt höre ich auf. Also High-Level-Depression wenn man so will. Das geht tatsächlich nahezu jedem Spieler irgendwann mal so, wenn er das nur als sagen wir mal Hobby betreibt. Dass man irgendwann merkt, also ich bin jetzt sozusagen hier der Experte geworden und deswegen wende ich mich jetzt etwas anderem zu.
Dem Menschen ist es zutiefst verinnerlicht, zu lernen. Und das machen wir auch alle gerne. Wir machen das vor allen Dingen deswegen gerne, weil wir intrinsisch davon angetrieben werden. Und man kann sich höchstens die Frage stellen, ist es problematisch, zum Lernen extrinsische Motivationsfaktoren einzusetzen. Also angefangen von so was banalem wie einer Benotung in der Schule, bis hin zu, du bist nicht versetzt, weil deine Noten so schlecht sind und so weiter und dem Aspekt zu sagen, du musst heute viel schaffen, damit du irgendwann später einen guten Beruf erlernen kannst. Zum Beispiel einem 13-Jährigen. Wenn du immer schön toll lernst und gute Noten bekommst, wirst du irgendwann mal in deinem Leben später was davon haben. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Schwierigkeit, das Lernen an sich macht an sich immer Spaß. Aber es muss im Prinzip so strukturiert sein, dass der Lernerfolg auch spürbar ist und dass er sich nicht nur in irgendetwas abbildet wie so was abstrakten, wie beispielsweise einer Note.
Sondern, und das ist der zweite wichtige Punkt, der Spiele so effektiv beim Lernen macht, das Gefühl der Selbstwirksamkeit. Ich tue etwas in diesem System und dafür sind Computerspiele tatsächlich sehr geeignet, weil sie ein Feedback geben können auf das was ich tue und das was dann im System passiert meldet mir dann zurück, ist das eine erfolgreiche oder weniger erfolgreiche Strategie. Wenn ich in einem Aufbauspiel Wirtschaftsketten anfange zu bauen, ich fange an mit einer Holzhütte, nächste Produktionsstätte und so weiter und so weiter, dann ist das zwar kein Abbild der Realität, der Wirklichkeit, sondern es ist eine Vereinfachung, eine Abstraktion, aber mit Abstraktionen arbeiten wir immer. Aber es veranschaulicht bestimmte Prozesse, die aufeinander aufbauen und ich stelle also eine Holzhütte irgendwo hin und stelle fest, wenn ich mir das Spiel anschaue, okay es ist viel effektiver, eine Holzhütte direkt an den Wald zu stellen, als irgendwo in die Wüste.
Und das heißt, ich fange im Grunde genommen an, in der Pädagogik nennt man das Learning by Doing, ich fange im Grunde genommen an, Prozesse zu lernen, indem ich ein sofortiges Feedback oder auch ein von mir aus etwas späteres Feedback bekommen, auf das was ich da tue. Also es heißt, es ist sinnvoll, kann ich damit das Problem lösen oder nicht? Und deswegen kann man Spiele zum Lernen hervorragend nutzen. Was natürlich nicht heißen soll, dass alle Computerspiele dafür gedacht sind. Das ist natürlich klar. Man kann zwar feststellen, ja in jedem Spiel lerne ich irgendwas.
Aber sie könnten dafür gedacht sein?
Sie könnten dafür gedacht sein, dann sagt man, okay das sind Serious Games, die sind jetzt wirklich explizit dafür gedacht, etwas bestimmtes zu vermitteln, eine bestimmte Kompetenz zu vermitteln und dann gucken wir auch, ob das wirklich so funktioniert. Aber de facto lernen wir natürlich in allen Spielen irgendwas und nicht immer ist das vielleicht auch sinnvoll, was man da lernt, aber das wiederum hat überhaupt nichts mit dem Thema des Spiels zu tun. Und das ist die Diskussion, die in den letzten Jahren viel zu häufig und teilweise auch falsch geführt wurden, nämlich zu sagen, es ist ein bestimmtes Genre, sagen wir mal ein Egoshooter, da lernen wir, Thema ist irgendwie eine Auseinandersetzung zum Beispiel mit dem Krieg und dann lernen wir sozusagen das Thema. Also vom Prinzip her ist das natürlich blödsinnig, weil was ich lerne ist nicht – ich lerne ja zum Beispiel in einem Jump n Run nicht springen und laufen, sondern da steuere ich eine Figur, die dann, das Gameplay ist springen und laufen und was lerne ich? Ich lerne eine bestimmte Form der Hand-Auge-Koordination.
Eine bestimmte Form der Geschicklichkeit. Das heißt es ist immer eine Abstraktion. Deswegen muss man sich eben sehr genau anschauen, was eigentlich wird vermittelt? Also wenn ich ein Spiel habe, wo ich sehr schnell reagieren muss, es ist immer klassisch Hand-Auge-Koordination, Geschicklichkeit, Reaktionsvermögen. Wenn es in einem 3D-Raum stattfindet, in einem sehr verwinkelten vielleicht, dann lerne ich räumliches Vorstellungsvermögen und so weiter. Wenn ich sage, ich will mit einem Computerspiel Mathekenntnisse vermitteln, kann man das mit Sicherheit tun, aber man tut es nicht, indem man jetzt Matheaufgaben wie in einem Mathebuch darstellt und dann was weiß ich, einfach einen Lehrtext angibt und hinterher ein Häkchen dahinter macht, ist richtig, sondern man würde versuchen, in einem Spiel eine Aufgabe zu finden, wofür man diese Matheformel braucht, um sie zu lösen.
Wenn ich also den Satz des Pythagoras vermitteln will, dann ist es doch viel sinnvoller, anstatt die Formel auswendig zu lernen, tatsächlich eine Umgebung zu schaffen, eine Spielherausforderung zu schaffen, in der ich den Satz des Pythagoras auch umsetzen muss, um dann zu merken, ah mit dieser Formel ist es mir möglich, diese Spielherausforderung zu lösen. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Problematik, dass man häufig denkt, bestimmte Genres haben einen bestimmten Effekt und das ist aber einfach nicht wahr. Es gibt ein Beispiel zu nennen, Spec Ops: The Line ist eben ein Egoshooter, der das Thema Krieg beinhaltet und was viele viele und gute positive Kritikerstimmen bekommen hat, weil es das Thema und das Genre eben so aufnimmt, dass es Gesellschaftskritik übt. Also sprich, es ist eigentlich man könnte fast sagen, ein Antikriegsspiel. Weil es dem Spieler vor Augen führt, was passiert, wenn sozusagen Entscheidungen getroffen werden müssen, die eben in sehr vielen Fällen in der Wirklichkeit auch dann wirklich zu Traumas führen, zu Traumata führen. Und deswegen ist das Spiel auch sehr gelobt worden, obwohl es sozusagen ein 18er Spiel ist.
Wird das Spiel denn auch gerne gespielt?
Also es gibt tatsächlich ganz viele interessante Walk Throughs von bekannten Lets Playern dazu, die auch sehr gemischt darauf reagieren. Natürlich erst mal total überrascht, weil sie da einen Spiegel vorgehalten bekommen, den sie so nicht kennen aus dem Genre. Es ist natürlich klar, dass das Genre bestimmte  …
Bestimmte Gewohnheiten sozusagen.
Gewohnheiten, Spielgewohnheiten, mit denen man da sozusagen in so ein Genre reingeht. Bestimmte Erwartungen hat. Aber viele empfanden das als unheimlich aufregend und spannend, dass sie so vor sich selbst mal gestellt wurden. Und auch so ein anderes Vorurteil, was häufig benannt wird, Spiele sind dazu da, zur Unterhaltung. Also in irgendeiner Form etwas oberflächliches adressieren. Und tatsächlich wenn man sich viele Spieler anschaut, die sich intensiv mit allen möglichen Genres beschäftigen, eben auch Lets Player, die das ja reflektieren auch, man merkt, dass tatsächlich Unterhaltung sehr allgemein gefasst natürlich schon einer der Gründe ist, aber wie entsteht Unterhaltung? Eben auch durch so was wie Eintauchen in durchaus eigene Abgründe, vertiefende Auseinandersetzungen mit bestimmten Dingen, die einem eben im Leben auch begegnen.
Und eben auch die Auseinandersetzung mit der Gesellschaft im allgemeinen, also sprich, gesellschaftskritische Spiele werden hervorragend angenommen. Also gerade in den letzten 2-3 Jahren merkt man das immer wieder, Spiele wie „This War of Mine“ beispielsweise haben mit die höchste Wertung bekommen auf Steam in den letzten Jahren.
Werden die von denselben Leuten angenommen, die auch bisher andere Spiele angenommen haben oder ist das eine andere Gattung von Spielern, die jetzt hier ins Feld kommt?
Also es gibt sicher viele Spieler, die nur ein bestimmtes Genre spielen, aber grundsätzlich, wenn man jetzt sagen wir mal von der Steam-Community ausgeht, die solche Bewertungen ja macht, jemand der Steam hat, ist normalerweise auch jemand, der so im Bereich Intensivspieler durchaus zu suchen ist und wenn man sich die Kommentare dann häufig dazu anliest, dann vergleichen die auch schon, was spielen sie sonst normalerweise. Und das heißt man sieht eigentlich auch schon, dass das Bild relativ groß ist, was sich die Spieler von den Spielen machen. Also relativ intensive Auseinandersetzung geht damit einher. Also das sind in der Regel schon, das ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, sind das jetzt Hardcoregamer oder Vielspieler, also ohne die Zielgruppen jetzt explizit zu benennen, muss man sagen, Menschen die sich viel mit Spielen auseinandersetzen tun das in der Regel auch auf einem Niveau, das sehr reflektiert ist und auch durchaus sehr kritisch sein kann.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall, wie soll ich sagen, einen kulturellen – vielleicht nicht Wandel – aber eine Weiterentwicklung, die da stattfindet? Es kommt was neues hinzu. Also dieser Begriff Serious Games, ich weiß nicht, wie lange gibt es den schon?
Also den Begriff gibt es tatsächlich länger als man meint, aber etabliert hat er sich erst so Anfang der 2000er, aber es gab schon ganz früh so in den 70er Jahren gab es ein Spiel „Origon Trail“ oder so ähnlich hieß das, das hat ein Lehrer in den USA hat da so ein kleines Spiel gemacht, um seinen Schülern die Geschichte der Einwanderung in die USA so ein bisschen näher zu bringen. Und das könnte man ja schon als Serious Game bezeichnen und ist auch noch die Frage, ist auch immer noch bis heute eine Auseinandersetzung, ist Serious Game eigentlich bezieht sich das jetzt nur auf reine Computerspiele oder kann auch ein Brettspiel ein Serious Game sein. Also gemeint ist damit eigentlich nur, dass man die Spielprinzipien oder das Spiel bewusst nutzt, um etwas bestimmtes zu kommunizieren. Und man würde jetzt über Spec Ops: The Line wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt Serious Game schreiben.
Aber vielleicht ist der Begriff auch einfach ein bisschen schwierig insgesamt. Wir übersetzen das immer gerne mit ernsthaft. Menschen die spielen sind sowieso immer ernsthaft, in dem Moment wo sie jetzt kurz davor sind, zu gewinnen oder zu verlieren, dann ist das das wichtigste in diesem Moment.
Da gibt es mal wieder keinen guten deutschen Begriff, den man jetzt so ohne weiteres verwenden könnte?
Ja manche sprechen von applied Games oder meaningful Games, aber das sind alles eigentlich Krücken, weil so ähnlich wie das mit anderen Medien auch ist, wir würden wahrscheinlich auch beim Fernsehen oder beim Film davon sprechen, es gibt eben Filme, auch diesen furchtbaren Begriff, anspruchsvoll oder Arthouse oder künstlerisch oder so was. Und insofern ist das eine Krücke, das muss man zugeben. Also gemeint ist eigentlich mit Serious Games nur, dass ich dann sozusagen einen bestimmten Zweck mir raussuche und schaue, wie ich ein sinnvolles Spielprinzip entwickele, um das was ich damit vermitteln will bestmöglich rüber zu bringen. Das heißt es eigentlich nur. Aber das heißt nicht, dass alle anderen Spiele nicht dazu geeignet sind, dass man was lernt, sie sind nur nicht dafür gedacht.
Ist ja jetzt sagen wir mal auch ein interessanter Aspekt, mit dem du dich auch selber viel beschäftigt hast, insbesondere in dem Zusammenhang hier auch mit der universitären Arbeit, nämlich was kann man jetzt aus der Erfahrung mit Spielen, oder aus konkreten Spielen auch heraus mitnehmen, was das Lernen als solches angeht? Also wenn da jetzt so viele Lernelemente drin sind und man so sehr Zeit und sich selbst investiert, um Systeme zu verstehen, um Zusammenhänge zu begreifen, Muster zu erkennen, Strategien zu entwickeln, Kampagnen zu fahren, all diese ganzen Stufen? Ich meine, das ist ja alles das was man auch im normalen Leben tun muss, wenn man sich selbst voranbringen will, wenn man ein Projekt voranbringen will, wenn man eine Firma aufbauen will. Das unterscheidet sich ja in dem Sinne auch überhaupt nicht.
Wenn der Lernaspekt ohnehin so stark ist, könnte man ja auch sagen, in diesen Spielen ist auch viel zu holen für, wie eigne ich mir überhaupt mein Wissen an, wie lerne ich gerade in so einer Phase des Studiums und der Ausbildung, wo das Lernen ja auch irgendwo im Mittelpunkt steht.
Also ich glaube zwei Dinge sind da wirklich entscheidende Fragestellungen. Die eine ist die, lernen wir eigentlich wirklich auf die richtige Art und Weise, wenn wir uns Wissen reinziehen, auf irgendwelche Art und Weise? Man spricht ja nicht ohne Grund von der Akademikerbulemie. Ich lerne das alles irgendwie auswendig, schreibe dann die Klausur so irgendwie und danach vergesse ich alles wieder. Für manche Studiengänge vielleicht zum Teil auch unabdingbar das nicht zu bestreiten. Aber es wäre natürlich durchaus denkens- und wünschenswert, andere Methoden zu finden, außer denen sozusagen nur das Wissen in irgendeiner Form kontextlos in sich aufzunehmen, also sprich auswendig zu lernen. Sondern das Wissen in irgendeiner Form zu erwerben, die Kompetenzen in irgendeiner Form zu erwerben und da sind Spiele als Belohnungssysteme sozusagen und Feedbacksysteme absolut geeignet dafür.
Das ist eine wichtige Fragestellung. Das heißt, man kann darüber nachdenken und das tun wir hier auch intensiv, wie kann man die Wissensvermittlung, was ja Hochschulen meistens tun, Kompetenzvermittlung, in künstlerischen Studiengängen auf jeden Fall auch, und nicht nur dort, also Wissens- und Kompetenzvermittlung, wie kann man das auf eine Art und Weise tun, die mehr Involviertheit seitens der Lehrenden erfordert. Also sprich einbeziehen, selber umsetzen. Spielprinzipien sind dazu sehr geeignet, weil sie eben die Möglichkeit schaffen, zu konstruieren. Also sprich, ich kann ein System schaffen, in dem Probleme gelöst werden müssen und ich kann selber nachvollziehen, wie das Problem gelöst wurde. Der andere Punkt ist das was eben sehr speziell ist für Gamesstudiengänge ist, wie können wir sozusagen die Komplexität der Spieleentwicklung vermitteln und verbessern.
Das ist ja sinnvollerweise auch nicht alleine durch Wissensvermittlung umzusetzen. Und das bedeutet, dass im Grunde genommen, also das ist das was ich am Anfang sagte, warum wir so viele Projekte machen, die auch die eigenen Ideen der Studierenden mit aufnimmt, sie müssen im Grunde genommen ein Proof of Concept liefern, warum die Ideen, die sie ursprünglich haben, ob sie funktionieren oder nicht als Spiel und das ist gar keine so kleine Herausforderung. Denn ein Spiel – ich sage es jetzt mal auch wieder ein bisschen in Anführungszeichen – keinen Spaß macht, hat sein Ziel letzten Endes verfehlt. Es gibt natürlich ein bestimmtes Genre, also Non-Games, was sagt, diese Spiele wollen gar keinen Spaß machen, die haben aber eine andere Funktion, die will ich jetzt mal außen vor lassen. Aber ansonsten funktioniert ein Spiel nur dann, wenn es tatsächlich irgendeine Form von Freude bereitet.
Also einen gewissen Unterhaltungswert hat. Und der wiederum entsteht nur dann, wenn ich tatsächlich mit dem Spiel was lernen kann. Wenn es zu einfach ist, wenn es zu schwierig ist, wenn das Feedbacksystem nicht gut funktioniert, wenn die Kommunikation im Spiel zum Spieler nicht gut funktioniert, dann macht es keinen Spaß. Also es sind so viele Komponenten, die dazu führen, und der wichtigste Punkt ist eben der, ich muss immer herausgefordert werden als Spieler, darf aber nicht überfordert werden. Im Prinzip vergleichbar und da sieht man eigentlich, wie nahe spielen und lernen aneinander sind, die Flow-Theorie. Die Flow-Theorie in der Lerntheorie ist identisch mit der Flow-Theorie in der Spieletheorie.
Was ist die Flow-Theorie?
Also im Grunde genommen wird mit der Flow-Theorie der Moment bezeichnet, wo ich komplett eintauche, in eine zu bewältigende Aufgabe. Damit ist nicht gemeint jetzt, das was manchmal verwechselt wird, also es ist nicht Immersion mit gemeint, ich tauche ein in ein ganz tolles Serienformat und ziehe mir eine Folge nach der anderen rein, das ist Immersion, ich bin also ganz in dem Thema. Sondern mit Flow ist gemeint, ich beschäftige mich mit einer Aufgabe und bin so sehr vertieft darin, dass ich im Prinzip ganz und gar darin aufgehe, bis ich die Aufgabe gelöst habe. Und in der Lerntheorie ist das ganz wichtig, weil wir haben innerhalb dieses Flows die ideale Lerneffizienz, aber unterhalb Langeweile und oben drüber eben Überforderung. Und das ist etwas, was sehr häufig auch passiert in Schulen, Hochschulen, Weiterbildungen, der eine fühlt sich immer ein bisschen unterfordert und steigt dann aus, der eine fühlt sich ein bisschen überfordert und man muss im Grunde genommen versuchen, alle irgendwie zusammenzubringen.
So irgendwie in der Mitte, dass so jeder ein bisschen was davon hat, aber eine ideale Lernsituation ist es häufig eben nicht. Weil irgendjemand immer sozusagen rechts oder links hinten rausfällt.
Wie nivelliert man das denn in einem guten Spiel? Was sind denn da sozusagen die Erfolgsstrategien, zu sagen, ich mache hier weder Überforderung noch Unterforderung, sondern ich lasse alle so in diesem vitalen Zwischenzustand, in dem man immer noch ein bisschen mehr einen drauf legen kann und auch nicht aufhören will?
Ja es gibt tatsächlich Unterschiede bei den Genres. Also bei den Point and Click-Adventures gibt es zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, zu sagen, okay die Rätsel sind zwar irgendwie so für 12-15 jährige gedacht, relativ schwierig und herausfordernd, aber wenn es jetzt jemand spielt, der noch jünger ist oder nicht gleich dahinterkommt oder so was, wenn er nach 10 Minuten davor sitzt vor dem Rätsel und nicht drauf kommt, dann bieten wir eben eine Hilfe an in Form von Hotspot oder so was. Das ist jetzt eine ganz simple Möglichkeit.
Hotspot ist dann was?
Wenn mir jetzt plötzlich das Spiel sagt, du hier ist das was du suchst.
Ach so Tipp geben sozusagen.
Im Prinzip ja.
Oder einfach einen Pilz fressen und dann geht es auch weiter.
Oder so was ja. Und wenn man das aber extrapoliert, also die technischen Möglichkeiten nimmt, die es gibt, ist immer der Moment, wo ich mit dem Spiel interagiere, ist das Spiel in der Lage, das zu sehen, was ich da tue. Und wenn er merkt, immer an der selben Stelle schafft er das Level nicht und das ist nicht nur einer, sondern das sind viele. Das ist das was in Testverfahren gemacht wird. Und da sagt man sich, musste der jetzt an dieser Stelle scheitern, ist das so gewollt vom Gamedesigner? Nein, eigentlich nicht, das soll eigentlich eine einfache Stelle sein, okay, dann kann man das erst mal ändern. Individualisieren kann man es auf genau dieselbe Art und Weise. Ich lese nicht nur sozusagen die Daten aller Spieler aus, sondern nur eines einzigen und stelle eben fest, wie schnell wie leicht kommt er da durch? Also wir kennen das jetzt halt durch diese üblichen Schwierigkeitsgrade, machst du dieses Spielegenre zum ersten Mal, brauchst du erst mal eine Einführung, möchtest du das Tutorial noch mal machen, du kannst sagen leicht, mittel, schwer.
Was immer das dann bedeutet, das weiß man ja nicht, wenn man das Spiel noch nie gespielt hat. Das ist so die Krücke. Inzwischen aber geht das viel weiter. Man kann im Grunde genommen heute sehr wohl herauslesen, - also nicht alle Spiele machen das natürlich – aber es ist möglich, herauszulesen, wie gut kommt der Spieler mit dem Spiel zurecht. Müssen wir die Herausforderung quasi in Realtime etwas runter fahren. Also wird das Spiel leichter sozusagen, wenn man merkt, der Spieler kommt nicht so zurecht, wie er normalerweise zurechtkommen sollte. Oder umgekehrt, er kommt viel zu gut zurecht, machen wir es dann ein bisschen schwerer. Also gehen tut das schon, ist allerdings auch nicht so ganz einfach, weil Spieler so was auch schnell merken.
Aber wenn man das jetzt mal auf den Hochschulbetrieb überträgt? Also hier vielleicht mal auch auf den konkreten Studiengang, was heißt denn das dann? Gibt es schon Aspekte des Spielens mit Computerspielen, die jetzt hier auch schon konkret umgesetzt hast, die jetzt sozusagen angewendet werden?
Also gamifizierter Unterricht sozusagen?
Ja weiß ich nicht, ob das darauf hinausläuft. Ich weiß nicht, ob alle jetzt erst mal Sterne von der Decke holen müssen, bevor sie in den nächsten Raum dürfen.
Also was wir tatsächlich machen, ja also das wünsche ich mir schon seit langem, und mehr und mehr versuche ich, das auch umzusetzen. Aber was wir hier vor allem machen ist, viel zu spielen tatsächlich, aber sofort auch zu analysieren, was tun wir da eigentlich. Das ist klar einfach mit Brettspielen, Kartenspielen, damit fangen wir in der Regel an und gehen dann eben eine Ebene weiter. Weil bei Brett- und Kartenspielen, da kann ich das Regelwerk durchschauen, da habe ich es ja sogar schriftlich daneben liegen, bei Computerspielen lässt sich das nicht so einfach durchschauen. Das heißt wir spielen sehr viel und analysieren dann aber auch nach den unterschiedlichen Aspekten. Welche Spielprinzipien stecken dahinter? Welche Mechanik wird angesetzt? Was ist, wenn ich bestimmte gesetzte Dinge ändere? Wie zum Beispiel den Aspekt, vollständige Information, unvollständige Information. Also es gibt eben eine ganze Menge Kriterien, die ich ansetzen kann, um ein Regelwerk zu verändern oder es zu optimieren.
Ein ganz einfaches Beispiel, nehmen wir mal Pong, weil wir schon drüber gesprochen haben. Was wäre, wenn Pong ein Spiel mit unvollständigen Informationen wäre? Das würde bedeuten, ich sehe quasi nur meine Seite, ich sehe also meinen Schläger und ich sehe ab der Seite, wo der Strich in der Mitte ist, sehe ich erst das Spielfeld. Das heißt, ich habe viel weniger Zeit zu reagieren und sehe nicht, von wo der Ball kommt und dadurch würde das Spiel unglaublich viel schwieriger werden. Schneller wahrscheinlich auch, aber vielleicht auch weniger taktisch, mehr sozusagen nur auf Hand-Augen-Koordination, aber nicht mehr so taktisch, weil ich nicht weiß, wo der andere Spieler steht. Und so was machen wir tatsächlich dann indem wir es versuchen einfach. Wir schauen uns diese Spielregeln an und verändern sie zum Beispiel. Und reflektieren darüber, okay was bedeutet das? Und diese Bedeutung, wie können wir das nutzen für andere Zwecke?
Okay, aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch ein Beispiel, wo es schon auch um das Erlernen von Spielen geht. Ich meine, hier gibt es Gamedesign. Klar, dass man sich mit Spielen als solchen auseinandersetzen muss und den Dynamiken und Fragestellungen, die damit verbunden sind. Aber wenn wir das jetzt mal einen Schritt weiter treiben und sagen, okay wir überlegen, welchen Einfluss können Spiele oder die Erkenntnisse, die wir jetzt aus dem Studium davon haben über die Zeit, einfließen lassen in diese Akademikerbulemie. Also sozusagen da so mal ein bisschen Schlankheitskur einkehren zu lassen und sich nicht immer alles reinzufressen. Also würde dir da was einfallen, wie man da sozusagen auch Empfehlungen an einen normalen Lehrbetrieb oder an einen nicht unmittelbar mit Spielen verbundenen Lehrbereich Erfahrungen übertragen kann?
Na ich glaube, man muss sich erst mal grundsätzlich die Frage stellen, was man überhaupt möchte. Möchte man Menschen etwas beibringen, was sie dann weitertragen? So ganz im Sinne von, ich stehe auf den Schultern eines Riesen und das bedeutet, ich muss erst mal so und so viel Material selber haben, bevor ich überhaupt alleine loslegen kann. Und je nachdem, in welchem Studiengang ich mich befinde oder in welchem Lehrgebiet ist der Anteil dessen, was ich sozusagen von anderen erfahren muss, relativ groß. Die Frage ist, muss man das auswendig lernen? Nein, da gibt es sicher ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Da zum Beispiel würde sich wirklich anbieten, so was in spielerische Kontexte umzusetzen. Aber ich denke, ein zweiter vielleicht noch spannenderer Punkt ist, sich zu vergegenwärtigen, wie häufig sich das Wissen der Welt verdoppelt. Man sagt so, alle drei Jahre verdoppelt sich das Wissen der Welt.
Von wem kann man denn verlangen, selbst auf seinem eigenen Fachgebiet, alles zu wissen? Also wie viel Wissen, Bildung brauch ich denn überhaupt und wie viel mehr Kompetenz brauche ich in Bezug auf, wie kann ich selber Probleme lösen? Letzten Endes es gibt viele Professoren, die verbieten die Nutzung eines Computers, Internet, Skripte, Bücher oder so was bei einer Klausur. Ich bin ganz offen, ich halte das tatsächlich für wenig sinnvoll. Zumindest im Hinblick darauf, dass ich später mal irgendwann einen Job habe, wahrscheinlich in einem Büro sitze, wahrscheinlich Internet habe, wahrscheinlich Bücher im Regal habe, warum soll ich das nicht nutzen? Also warum soll mir das Wissen der Welt zu meinem Fachgebiet nicht permanent zur Verfügung stehen? Vielmehr wäre es doch überlegenswert, zu sagen, um zu wissen, was der Mensch, der da jetzt sitzt und seine Klausur oder was auch immer schreibt, wirklich kann, ist, stell ihm doch alles zur Verfügung was es gibt und stell einfach andere Fragen und guck mal, was er daraus macht.
Es muss nicht unbedingt immer nur im Bezug auf den Beruf sein. Das ist ganz klar, ich meine wir sind eine Hochschule, wir sind stärker an der Berufspraxis orientiert als eine Universität. Aber dennoch, was wir doch eigentlich wollen sind Menschen, die …
... Strategien entwickeln.
... die Strategien entwickeln, die Problemlösungen entwickeln. Wir bringen den Leuten nicht Word bei, damit sie jeden einzelnen Punkt, der Word kann, beherrschen können, sondern wir bringen den Leuten bei, tolle Romane zu schreiben, wenn man so will, um das zu übersetzen, oder Bestseller zu schreiben, ganz egal, welches Programm sie dafür benutzen. Also nur Word zu beherrschen führt ja nicht dazu, dass ich Bestseller schreiben kann. Und das heißt, wir versuchen eben – also manche nennen es Metakompetenzen – also wir versuchen, Studenten zu befähigen, das was sie in sich haben zu finden, also ihre Potenziale zu finden, aber sie dann auch entsprechend umzusetzen. Und natürlich gehört dazu das Beherrschen von Werkzeugen. Natürlich geht dazu ein gewisses Wissen, ein Wissensschatz, das ist gar keine Frage. Aber das sind alles nur Tools. Was wir eigentlich brauchen in der modernen Gesellschaft sind Menschen, die in der Lage sind, Probleme anzupacken und Entscheidungen zu treffen und die Konsequenzen der Entscheidungen in irgendeiner Form mit in ihren Entscheidungsprozess einzubeziehen.
Was mich ja mal interessieren würde, die Studenten, die hier sich jetzt so intensiv mit Gamedesign auseinandersetzen – ich vermute mal, dass ein Großteil von denen auch schon eine ganz erkleckliche Spielevergangenheit in ihrer Jugend zurückgelegt haben dürfte?
Ja.
Ist an denen irgendwas anders? Also wenn man das mal mit unserer Generation vielleicht vergleicht, wo das noch nicht ganz so verbreitet war. Also sind da irgendwie andere Methoden des Lernens schon irgendwie vollkommen normal und eingebaut, so dass man das noch gar nicht mal mehr ansprechen muss? Gibt es da irgendwie eine Bereitschaft oder vielleicht auch eine Verweigerung bestimmten Dingen, Systematiken gegenüber? Kann man da irgendwas rauslesen oder denke ich mich da jetzt schon viel zu tief rein?
Also das Problem ist das mit dem Vergleich. Also ich habe tatsächlich schon ein paar kleine Vergleiche, aber nicht unbedingt, ich will jetzt nicht unbedingt über die Studenten reden, aber zu anderen Studiengängen. Also ich habe mal in einem Studiengang Management, Medienmanagement auch unterrichtet und da ist es völlig üblich gewesen, Klausuren zu schreiben. Habe ich zu dem Zeitpunkt aber auch bei Gamedesign gemacht. Allerdings habe ich Klausuren da ja eben anders geschrieben, wie ich das ja eben schon berichtet habe. Aber im Medienmanagement habe ich durchaus gemerkt, dass die Grundmentalität dieser Studierenden eine andere ist, nämlich die dass ihnen vor allen Dingen Noten wichtig sind, also dass die externe Beurteilung extrem wichtig ist und dass sie alles dafür tun, dass sie besonders gut ist. Bis hin dazu, was ich vorher nie erlebt habe, dass da jeder zweite versucht hat, zu pfuschen. Und das was ich ein bisschen grotesk daran finde ist, dass wenn ich sage, ihr könnt eure Skripte benutzen, warum pfuscht dann eigentlich noch jemand? Das frage ich mich übrigens bis heute, warum die das gemacht haben. Aber das scheint so eine Art Automatismus gewesen zu sein.
Also Pfuschen im Sinne von was?
Im Sinne von, irgendwie irgendwo ein Zettelchen verstecken, weil mir das keiner so richtig geglaubt hat, wenn ich sage, ihr könnt euer Skript benutzen, dass man das tatsächlich benutzen kann. Also das sind aber eher unterschiedliche Auffassungen innerhalb bestimmter Studiengänge, das hat nicht unbedingt was mit den Studenten zu tun. Zweite Erfahrung, die ich gemacht habe ist, als ich die erste Klausur auf diese Art und Weise geschrieben habe, nämlich zu sagen, ihr könnt alles benutzen, mir die Studenten hinterher gesagt haben, das war eigentlich viel schwieriger als sonst. Also da wo ich noch wusste, was ich alles auswendig lernen muss, das ist viel einfacher.
Weil einfach was ganz anderes gefordert ist.
Ganz genau, weil es darum ging, was kannst du mit dem was du hast entwickeln, um eine Fragestellung, ein Problem zu beantworten oder dir was auch immer zu erarbeiten. Also wenn es zum Beispiel um wissenschaftliche Fragestellungen ging, dann hilft einem das ja nichts, irgendwas irgendwo raus abzuschreiben, sondern muss man eigene Gedanken entwickeln und selbst reflektieren. Und da ich das dann relativ häufig gehört habe von Studenten, vor allem von denen, die jetzt gerade von der Schule kommen, habe ich natürlich irgendwann angefangen, das zu hinterfragen, woran liegt denn das? Und nachdem ich ja auch selbst eine Tochter großgezogen habe, ich meine es liegt natürlich zum Teil daran, dass es häufig die Auffassung gibt innerhalb von Lehrsystemen oder Lehrbetrieben, es gibt richtig und falsch. Und de facto ist das einfach eine viel zu kurze Möglichkeit, Dinge zu erklären. Es gibt nicht richtig und falsch, sondern es gibt immer unterschiedliche Entscheidungen, die unterschiedliche Konsequenzen haben und die muss man reflektieren und dann in irgendeiner Form dazu eine Position beziehen.
Und das ist das, was wir viel mehr beibringen und unterrichten sollten. Also wenn wir schon von unterrichten sprechen. Nämlich, dass unterschiedliche Entscheidungen unterschiedliche Konsequenzen nach sich ziehen und man kann vielleicht noch nicht mal unbedingt immer sagen, was ist richtig und was ist falsch. Und gerade jetzt in einem Designstudiengang müsste man ja die Frage stellen, ist grün besser als rot? Darauf kann man keine eindeutige Antwort geben. Das wird man niemals können, weil grün ist nicht besser als rot oder irgendeine andere Farbe. In einem bestimmten Kontext allerdings gibt es vielleicht nur die Entscheidung für ein bestimmtes Logo für ein bestimmtes Unternehmen eben die Farbe grün oder rot zu wählen oder vielleicht eine Kombination aus beiden und dann macht es in diesem Kontext ergibt es Sinn, aber es gibt kein Richtig oder Falsch.
Jetzt muss ich aber da nochmal fragen, ob bei den durch Spiele geprägten Studenten das dann auch anders ist?
Also ich habe durchaus ja eine ganze Menge kennengelernt, eine ganze Menge Studenten kennengelernt und ich kann nicht jetzt sagen, die sind irgendwie ganz anders als Jurastudenten, das sind sie mit Sicherheit, aber ich kann den Vergleich nicht wirklich heranziehen. Den einzigen Vergleich, den ich habe, den habe ich eben genannt. Was ich aber merke ist ein unglaublich hohes Engagement, und zwar an allen Hochschulen, an denen ich war. Ich war ja an mehreren. Ich habe von Gamedesign-Studenten immer nur mitbekommen, die würden am liebsten am Wochenende noch da sein, ihre Projekte machen. Die sitzen bis abends und machen zusammen ihre Projekte. In der Tendenz also sehr engagiert, sehr teamfreudig, was übrigens nicht immer heißt, dass sie immer teamfähig sind, aber teamfreudig. Und am liebsten würden sie mehrere Projekte auf einmal machen. Organisieren selber zum Beispiel Gamejams hier an der Hochschule, da erlebe ich das. Die Game-Dev-Week, eine ganze Woche, wird alles organisiert von Studenten.
Also dieses die Vorlesungen ist vorbei und ich gehe nach Hause, das gibt es eigentlich fast gar nicht.
Ja gut, aber okay, dann ist die Motivation hoch, aber ist sagen wir mal auch in der Art und Weise wie jetzt an strategische Fragen ran gegangen wird, also gibt es zum Beispiel eine andere Bereitschaft, also das höre ich jetzt so ein bisschen raus, dass es schon mal grundsätzlich eine andere Bereitschaft gibt, solche strategischen Fragestellungen auch anzunehmen. Ist das dann einfach so oder ist das irgendwie ... also ist das sozusagen etwas, was von der Auseinandersetzung mit Spielen kommen kann?
Also ich denke ja. Also es ist halt immer schwierig, zu sagen, nur weil ich davon überzeugt bin, ist das kein Beweis. Ich denke ja, weil ich seit eben 2007 immer die Erfahrung gemacht habe, dass die Herangehensweise auch durchaus unterschiedlich ist und auch, dass man sich, wenn man sich dafür entscheidet, in diesem Bereich was zu machen, offensichtlich die hohe Eigenmotivation, du hast es eben angesprochen, ist ja relativ typisch auch für die Branche, man spricht ja von Herzblutbranche, also keiner studiert Gamedesign, weil er irgendwann später Bankmanager werden will, obwohl es vielleicht trotzdem funktionieren würde. Aber es geht schon darum, dass die, die sich in dem Bereich engagieren, das auch wirklich machen wollen. Und sehr viele von denen lassen sich in der Tat eher ungern etwas vorschreiben. Also sie möchten schon gerne ein Stück weit Selbstentfaltung, Selbstgestaltung darin sehen und wehren sich wenn dann vor allen Dingen dagegen, das zu machen was andere gemacht haben.
Also irgendwas zu kopieren, was andere schon gemacht haben und es genauso zu machen zum Beispiel das eher nicht, sondern eigene Lösungen zu finden für die Problemstellungen, die sie sich eben zum Teil auch selbst gegeben haben. Das ist mein Eindruck, aber das ist natürlich kein Beweis.
Wenn ich jetzt nochmal diesen Bereich, also wir hatten ja vorhin diese Serious-Games, was da ja im Prinzip dahinter steckt ist, sozusagen Spiele nutzen zum Lernen oder zum Lehren, je nachdem. Und das gibt es ja nun auch schon länger und wir hatten ja dieses Beispiel mit diesem Origon Trail, der sozusagen schon sehr früh im Prinzip genau das zum Ziel gehabt hat. Ist das jetzt nur so eine Grille in der Vergangenheit oder ist das etwas, was sich jetzt auch langsam verbreitet? Also welche Rolle können Spiele selber beim Lehren haben oder haben sie derzeit?
Also haben sie tatsächlich schon. Also man entwickelt zwar nach wie vor immer noch verschwindet in geringer Anzahl Spiele, die explizit als Serious-Games zu bezeichnen sind, also klar verschwindend gering im Sinne von, gemessen am Restumsatz, was so umgesetzt wird mit Blogbustern. Nichts desto trotz findet man mehr und mehr Spiele, die auch mit einem sagen wir mal inzwischen halbwegs respektablen Budget entwickelt werden. Ich erinnere mich da na Ludwig, das ist ein Spiel, was man in Österreich entwickelt hat für Schulen und den Physikunterricht, ich glaube der 10. und 11. Klasse oder so was, und wo man wirklich ein komplettes Curriculum umgesetzt hat für ein Jahr, quasi als Ersatz oder zusätzlich zum Lehrstoff und der tatsächlich einen ganzen Lernstoff enthält, aber eben als Spiel. Und was unglaublich gut angenommen wird.
Und mit diesen Erfahrungen, die man macht mehr und mehr, es gibt ja noch viele andere Beispiele und die Effektivität und Effizienz auch messen kann, auch positiv messen kann, desto mehr ist man auch bereit dazu, zu sagen, okay wir investieren da jetzt auch mal größere Budgets, das ist nämlich so das Hauptproblem, dass man da eben so wenig Geld in der Regel reinzustecken bereit ist. Wir investieren auch mal größere Budgets, weil wir sehen, dass es funktionieren kann, mit Spielen eben anstatt anderer Lernmittel zu operieren. Auf der anderen Seite und das ist glaube ich eine Tendenz, die wird noch stärker zunehmen, versucht man einfach, die Spiele, die es schon gibt, in Kontext von Lehre und Lernen einzubinden. Ein ganz profanes Beispiel, aber ebenso spannend, viele Lehrer benutzen inzwischen Minecraft im Unterricht. Stellen Aufgaben wie, baut doch mal den Eiffelturm nach im Erdkundeunterricht.
Also ist im Prinzip das digitale Lego.
Genau. Und damit kann man natürlich hervorragend arbeiten. Also man kann damit hervorragend Aufgabenstellungen rausgeben, die so in dieser Form wahrscheinlich gar nicht mit analogen Dingen umzusetzen wären.
Was sind dann die Ziele, die damit verwirklicht werden sollen? Also wozu lässt sich Minecraft jetzt konkret zum Beispiel nutzen?
Also Minecraft ist ja eigentlich eher so eine Sandbox mit so einem kleinen Gameanteil. Das heißt also, ich kann hier wenn ich will ganze Welten bauen. Also sprich man kann so was eben typischerweise für Erdkunde, aber vielleicht auch für Geschichte benutzen. Sprich, Dinge nachbauen in der virtuellen Welt. Das ist ja im Prinzip ein Editor. Nachbauen in der virtuellen Welt, was eben sagen wir mal in der Wirklichkeit nicht möglich wäre. Ich kann es für Geschichte nutzen, weil ich Geschichte lebendig machen kann usw. So bieten eben diese virtuellen Wrkzeuge eben auch eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten.
Wer macht denn das? Also wer benutzt denn Minecraft in der Schule?
Also selbst in Deutschland gibt es schon viele Lehrer, die das machen.
Selbst in Deutschland, aber es fing hier nicht an oder?
In Skandinavien ist es in einigen Schulen schon Pflichtfach geworden tatsächlich.
Pflichtfach? Minecraft?
Ja.
So wie Englisch, Mathe, Minecraft.
Ja da geht es nicht nur darum, dass man das Spiel lernen muss, sondern dass man mit diesem Spiel als Werkzeug arbeitet. Also zum Beispiel Erdkunde und Geschichte.
Also nicht Minecraft ist das Pflichtfach, sondern ein Standartwerkzeug.
Das Werkzeug, ein Standartwerkzeug für den Unterricht geworden, ganz genau.
Aha und in welchen Disziplinen dann?
Wie gesagt, das kann man ja in unterschiedlichen Disziplinen anwenden. Typisch ist, also ich meine, in Minecraft wurde ja inzwischen schon alles nachgebaut. Ganz Mittelerde wurde da nachgebaut.
Computer.
Star Wars Universen und so weiter. Und da ist es natürlich möglich, quasi so was wie originalgetreue, also in dieser Welt originalgetreue, Dinge nachzubilden und das kann man in vielen Kontexten anwenden. Ich sagte ja schon Erdkunde oder Geschichte beispielsweise. Und wenn man eben so denkt, dass man sagt, wir unterrichten nicht nur Fächer, sondern wir unterrichten tatsächlich Schüler und Studenten statt Fächer, dann findet man auch noch viele andere Anwendungsmöglichkeiten. Auch in Deutschland an den Schulen wird es schon tatsächlich seit den 90er Jahren diskutiert sogar, zusammen mit dem Bundesamt für politische Bildung, kann man die existierenden Spiele nicht in den Kontext von bestimmten Fächern, zu denen sie sich eignen, stellen. Wie gerade in Geschichte. Es gibt viele Spiele, die eben geschichtliche Inhalte adressieren. Und da hat man dann natürlich zum Teil auch festgestellt, das ist nicht so unproblematisch. Die Spiele würden zwar zum Teil passen zu dem Thema.
Nehmen wir mal zweiter Weltkrieg, aber das Problem ist, das würde mit der USK nicht funktionieren. Das heißt also das was im Geschichtsbuch steht, kann für die 12. Klasse sozusagen rausgegeben werden, aber wenn man dasselbe in einem Spiel wiederfindet, funktioniert es nicht, weil es in der Regel 16er oder 18er Titel sind. Das ist so eine Problematik. Die andere Problematik ist, man muss natürlich auch eine gewisse Kenntnis haben. Also welche Spiele eignen sich denn überhaupt für welchen Unterricht? Und die eher jungen Lehrer, die also mit Spielen aufgewachsen sind, die wissen das eben aus eigener Anschauung. Einer hat mir mal geschrieben, ich habe Cultures gespielt, das benutze ich jetzt auch im Unterricht, um Geschichtswissen zu vermitteln. Oder Assissin's Creed, auch so ein typisches Beispiel. Also ein echter Action Blockbuster wenn man so will, aber die Szenarien, die in Assassin's Creed enthalten sind, referenzieren eben historische Ereignisse. Und viele, die das dann wirklich sehr intensiv gespielt haben, haben hinterher auch gesagt, jetzt weiß ich echt in Florenz so wo da alles so ist und keine Ahnung, ich habe Leonardo Da Vinci getroffen.
Obwohl sich das Spiel ja nicht selbst mit der Geschichte als solches auseinandersetzt, sondern eigentlich ja mehr als Kulisse benutzt oder?
Im Prinzip ja. Also die Hauptfigur ist ja im Prinzip immer eine fiktive Figur, aber in bestimmten historischen Ereignissen aktiv. Das heißt die fiktive Figur ist zwar erfunden, aber alles andere ist historisch authentisch sagen wir mal, nicht immer 100% bis ins kleinste Detail, das ist aber auch nicht der Anspruch. Weil Assassin's Creed ist ja eigentlich kein Serious Game, aber es funktioniert eben tatsächlich doch sehr gut. Also viele haben ein sehr gutes Bild von bestimmten Ereignissen. Nehmen wir von mir aus mal hier die Boston Tea Party, die ja in einem der Assissin's Creed Teile auch dargestellt wird und der Unterschied zu einem Film oder auch einem Buch, wo die Fakten drinstehen, oder ein Film, indem ja das alles mir als Geschichte erzählt wird, ist der, dass ich mich in einem Spiel sehr viel länger aufhalte.
Also das heißt, wenn ich in Boston unterwegs bin oder in Florenz unterwegs bin, dann laufe ich da ja nicht nur einmal durch und gucke mir das an, sondern ich habe ja ständig was zu tun als Spieler. Dann besuchst du erst mal den und dann den und dann lernst du plötzlich historische Figuren kennen, die dir dann irgendeinen Auftrag geben. Und dann stellst du irgendwann fest, nachdem du ein paar Stunden in diesem Spiel unterwegs warst, dass du die Gebäude alle kennst, du kennst die Wege dahin, du weißt, wer da damals gewohnt hat und hast zu vielen Gebäuden dann auch noch viel mehr Kontexte bekommen, einfach weil du es für den Spielverlauf gebraucht hast.
Okay, da kann ich jetzt sehr gut einen klaren Bedarf für den Geschichtsunterricht rauslesen. Aber damit wäre ja so die Naturwissenschaft jetzt noch nicht unbedingt mit bedient?
Also tatsächlich bietet es sich ja für die Naturwissenschaft ja fast noch viel mehr an, Spiele zu nutzen. Und für den Informatikunterricht gibt es auch schon wahnsinnig viele tolle Spiele, die sozusagen die ersten Schritte des Programmierens beibringen, ohne dass du irgendeinen Code schreiben musst, sondern nur das Grundprinzip. Naturwissenschaft ist es deshalb erst mal eigentlich einfacher, weil du eine viel bessere Möglichkeit, - also in der Naturwissenschaft funktionieren viele Dinge eben auch im Kontext von richtig und falsch. Ob das Mathe ist oder was auch immer. Das ist ein Vorteil. Das heißt, man kann es sozusagen computerseitig besser bewerten als richtig oder falsche Antwort. Der Nachteil ist allerdings, weil das so offensichtlich einfach ist, sind die meisten Spiele in dem Bereich tatsächlich nichts anderes als eine interaktive Umsetzung eines Mathebuches. Und damit hat man eben auch noch kein neues gutes Konzept gefunden, Naturwissenschaft besser zu vermitteln.
Aber nehmen wir beispielsweise mal so was wie ... - also es gibt so eine Menge Physikspiele. Welche fallen mir denn da jetzt ein? Angefangen von Portal. Portal ist kein Serious Game, sondern ein relativ erfolgreiches Mod von ... also mit der Source Engine also von Half Life letzten Ende, wo man im Grunde genommen Physikrätsel löst. Referenziert Naturwissenschaft, aber keine einzige Formel lernt oder so was. Sondern es geht nur darum, bestimmtes physikalisches Denken und Verhalten zu generieren. Nehmen wir so was wie Incredible Machine, wo ich irgendwelche Abläufe aufbauen muss, die dann irgendwie mit Zahnrädern und so weiter ineinandergreifen und funktionieren müssen. Ich kann es so lange ausprobieren, bis es funktioniert. Extrem erfolgreiches Format, eben genau deswegen, weil es eben sehr experimentell ist und sehr veranschaulichend. Und und und. Also es gibt wahnsinnig viele in dem Bereich, die das versuchen, eben über die Visualisierung und auch eben dadurch, dass wir jetzt in den letzten Jahren eine unglaubliche Weiterentwicklung in Sachen Physik-Engines haben.
Also das heißt, dass wir auch Physik wirklich abbilden könne in einer Engine, hat sich da wahnsinnig viel getan. Aber haben nach wie vor immer noch die Problematik, es müssen trotzdem irgendwie angemessene Spielformate sein, die sich eignen sozusagen naturwissenschaftliches Wissen zu vermitteln.
Das heißt das ist jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen die Herausforderung, die technische Basis, so etwas zu realisieren, ist im Prinzip da, jetzt geht es an die Inhalte und man muss sich sozusagen überlegen, was kann man für einen spielerischen Rahmen machen, um sagen wir mal mechanische Grundprinzipien zu erlernen. Könnte man sich ja einiges vorstellen, gibt es ja auch genug klassisches Material. Schneller sein, Prinzessin retten und darüber dann halt muss man erst mal eine Brücke bauen, weil sonst kommt man halt nicht rüber über den Canyon, aber man baut halt jetzt nicht die Brücke, indem man da auf den Zauberwürfel klickt, und dann hat man eine Brücke gebaut, sondern man muss sie halt wirklich bauen, man muss wirklich die einzelnen Komponenten zusammenstecken.
So wie den Bridge Constructor gibt es ja schon. Oder auch eben dieses großartige Spiel World of Goo, wo man im Grunde genommen eben auch mit Schwerkraft alle möglichen Sachen bauen muss, nur der Unterschied ist der, dass man es mit so kleinen Schleimkügelchen macht interessanterweise, die aber der Gravitation auch unterliegen und das ist so was wie ein Kartenbauspiel. Und die Physik die muss einfach nur annähernd korrekt sein, weil 100% korrekte Physik ist schon noch relativ schwierig, aber sie ist auch gar nicht immer unbedingt nötig. Das ist häufig so, dass es reicht, sehr nah dran zu sein und das Gefühl sehr gut zu simulieren oder die Physik sehr gut zu simulieren und das reicht in der Regel dann schon aus, um diesen Lerneffekt sozusagen zu vermitteln.
Wenn man sich jetzt schon bei so Egoshootern bedienen muss, um irgendwie Geschichtsunterricht zu bringen, dann könnte man eigentlich auch sagen …
Assassin's Creed ist kein Egoshooter.
Sondern? Entschuldigung, ich bin da nicht so bewandert.
Assassin's Creed ist ein Action Adventure. Und was man hauptsächlich macht ist, man klettert auf irgendwelche Türme oder Häuser oder was auch immer. Man kann durchaus auch den anderen massakrieren, das stimmt, man ist ja ein Assassine, wie der Name schon sagt, aber das ist nicht die Hauptherausforderung im Spiel.
Ich fang nochmal anders an. Also wenn man sich sozusagen jetzt um ein Geschichtsunterricht zu unterstützen sozusagen einfach eines Spiels bedient, was eigentlich gar nicht dafür gedacht war, und man möchte aber eigentlich etwas haben, womit man noch sehr viel mehr den eigentlichen Lehrauftrag modulieren kann, dann braucht man ja im Prinzip, muss man vielleicht mal an diesem Begriff Spiel auch einfach mal als solches fallen lassen und sagen, wir bauen jetzt hier ein modernes Lernmedium, eine interaktive kleine Welt, die in der Lage ist, die physische, die historische oder wie auch immer geartete Welt zu modellieren und erlebbar zu machen, eine Strategie entwickeln zu lassen etc., also dass man sozusagen alles das was eigentlich ein gutes Spiel auch ausmacht, hier mit dem Ziel des Erlernens neu gestaltet. Wer macht das? Also macht das schon jemand? Gibt es da einen Trend? Gibt es einen Studiengang, der sich mit den Erstellen solcher Lernmittel vielleicht auseinandersetzt? Sollte es einen geben?
Also wenn es ein solches Spiel gäbe, was das alles abbildete, das wäre tatsächlich hochinteressant, das in Vergleich zu setzen zu dem, was es eben an klassischen Lehrmitteln gibt. Was es tatsächlich gibt, ich fange mal da an, wo gespielt wird in der Schule, und zwar ist das eine Schule, die in den USA gegründet wurde. Das ist eine Schule, in der man nur durch Spiele lernt, allerdings werden da keine Spiele gemacht, sondern es werden durch Spiele eben Kompetenzen vermitteln. Und das tun sie seit ein paar Jahren. Das sind tatsächlich auch ehemalige Spieleentwickler, die das ins Leben gerufen haben und das ganz offensichtlich mit sehr großem Erfolg.
Wie heißt das?
School of Games nennen die sich glaube ich. Also Katie Salen und ursprünglich mal Eric Zimmerman haben die gegründet. Aber das ist noch nicht sozusagen die Art und Weise …
Nicht ganz das was du gefragt hast, sondern da geht es ja eher darum, wie könnte man so was tatsächlich umsetzen und die Antwort ist eigentlich erst mal ganz banal, dafür braucht es eine Menge Geld. Weil wenn ich mir Assassin's Creed anschaue, dann sitzen da durchaus über mehrere Jahre mehrere hundert Leute dran. Das heißt, wenn man es wirklich so aufwendig machen will, schlicht und ergreifend ein bedeutender finanzieller Aufwand, den man erst mal bringen muss, den man erst mal schaffen muss. Bis dahin allerdings kann man sehr wohl was anderes tun, man kann unterschiedliche Felder besetzen oder sagen, welche Spiele eignen sich denn heute schon für bestimmte Felder. Also sprich, kommerzielle Spiele, die auch wirklich schon entwickelt sind oder die mit Editoren daherkommen, dass man sie verändern kann usw. Und die dann einsetzen, das ist zum Beispiel was was wir hier auch machen.
Nicht so ganz das was ich meinte.
Wir bekommen von Spieleentwicklern sogenannte SDKs oder Engines oder was auch immer oder die Möglichkeit, oder irgendwelche Editoren, also die Möglichkeit sozusagen, ein bereits nahezu bestehendes Programm, also eine fertige Entwicklungsmaschine, wenn man so will, eine fertige Gameengine, ein fertiges Editorrahmenprogramm zu benutzen und das dann weiter zu entwickeln oder damit neue Inhalte zu erstellen. Das sind so die ersten Schritte, das macht man auch viel an Schulen. Man nimmt dann ganz einfach so was wie einen Gamemaker oder man nimmt Spiele, die ein eigenes Entwicklertool da dran haben, kann damit neue Levels bauen, neue Welten gestalten. Ich habe das schon vor Jahren an der Hochschule in Brandenburg gemacht mit einem uralten Spiel, Caesar glaube ich hieß das, das kam eben mit so einem kleinen Leveleditor daher und man konnte im Prinzip Städte und eine ganze Geschichte nachbilden, schon vor 10 Jahren war das total easy eigentlich.
Aber heute nennt man das Modding, nannte man damals natürlich auch schon so, aber de facto hat man das vorher noch niemals irgendwo in der Lehre eingesetzt, sondern das war eine reine Unterhaltungscommunity, also eine Spielercommunity, die das ja inzwischen mit jedem Spiel machen, solange du die Möglichkeit hast. Solange du in irgendeiner Form einen Editor dazu bekommst, wird das auch gemacht. Also das ist ja eine ganz interessante Entwicklung der jeweiligen Gamescommunitys, dass sie auch bereit sind und das referenziert vielleicht auch nochmal deine Frage von eben, also selbst Inhalte in diesem Framework zu erstellen und den dann auch öffentlich zu machen.
Na gut, dass sich da eine ganze Menge Tools und Librarys, Frameworks und Engines anbieten, da was zu machen, das sehe ich auch. Die Frage ist ja nur, wer kümmert sich sozusagen um den Layer da drüber? Also ich denke, es wird immer mehr geben und wir auch immer mehr auf Open Source Basis geben, so dass man sich nicht von irgendetwas abhängig macht, was dann irgendwie einfach so ohne weiteres wegstirbt. Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, man würde generell dem Lehrsystem Deutschlands, weltweit sozusagen diese Spielekomponente hinzufügen und man entwickelt explizit Systeme, die eben was weiß ich eben diesen historischen Aspekt abdecken. So dass man das nicht nur in Assassin's Creed drin hat, sondern dass man sozusagen das alte Florenz oder war es Venedig, ich weiß gar nicht?
Florenz unter anderem.
Wo auch immer man sich da rumtreibt, dass man das sozusagen erst mal so als Basis hat und dann eben anfängt, darin beliebige Geschichten zu erzählen. Heute geht es um die Medici und morgen geht es um Aspekte des Handels. Ist das sozusagen eine Herausforderung, die aufgenommen werden sollte oder führt das ins Nichts?
Ja unbedingt. Also das ist auch genau das, was wir hier zum Teil zumindest schon machen. Im Prinzip geht es in die Richtung, die ich eben gesagt habe, im Prinzip ist das erst mal eine Form von Modding. Du bekommst also erst mal ein Framework, wie auch immer das aussieht und entwickelst weitere Inhalte mit einem bestimmten Zweck. Nämlich zum Beispiel dem, dass man es in der Lehre einsetzen kann. Wir entwickeln ja auch tatsächlich, also viele Studierende entwickeln hier auch tatsächlich Serious Games Ansätze, weil die es sehr sehr spannend finden, hey was gibt es für Möglichkeiten, was weiß ich, wie ich besser 10-Finger-Schreiben lernen kann. Da haben wir hier ein ganz tolles 3D-Adventure. Usw. Aber es ist natürlich, was es explizit nicht gibt ist ein Studiengang, der sagt, genau das was du gerade beschrieben hast, machen wir jetzt. Was es aber gibt ist, und das ist ein Studiengang, der beginnt tatsächlich erst nächsten Sommer, der erste Studiengang, der sich mit dem Thema Lernsystemgestaltung beschäftigt.
Der in Stuttgart jetzt anlaufen wird und der dann tatsächlich der erste in Deutschland ist, der sich mit dem Thema Entwicklung neuer Lernsysteme unter Einbeziehung von Technologien, aber auch durchaus Games und Serious Games, allerdings nicht nur, aber eben auch e-Learning, verteiltes Lernen, Moocs und was weiß ich nicht auseinandersetzt, das gab es bisher tatsächlich noch gar nicht. Also so was kam eigentlich auch nicht über einen Studiengang, sondern meistens irgendwie über andere Mediengestalter beispielsweise oder so was. Aber jemand, der sich wirklich explizit als Forschungseinrichtung, als Lehreinrichtung, als Hochschule mit dem Thema Umsetzung von Lerninhalten auf allen Ebenen und mit allen Technologien beschäftigt, das ist tatsächlich neu.
Also ich habe ja auch so den Eindruck, es gibt da noch, also die Früchte hängen eigentlich so niedrig mittlerweile, dass man sich wundert, warum nicht schon alle die ganze Zeit zum Obstpflücker geworden sind. Wenn ich so denke, Lernen und Spielen, fällt mir gerade so ein ganz kleines Minispielchen auf, was so in der Wikipedia-Gemeinde gemacht wird, um einfach die Qualität der Wikipedia zu verbessern, wo so die ganzen Metadaten herausgekramt werden und man kann das so in einem kleinen Spielchen, wo man so einen Highscore bilden kann, kriegt man sozusagen immer so Fakten, die man bewerten muss oder wie rum ist es und diese Person, ist diese Person ein Mann? Ist diese Person ein Schauspieler etc. wodurch dann sozusagen spielerisch auch das Weltwissen verbessert wird.
Ja das ist jetzt sagen wir mal so ein ganz kleiner Ansatz, um dieses spielerische in die Qualitätsverbesserung reinzubringen. Aber auf der anderen Seite sind natürlich auch solche Archive wie die Wikipedia natürlich auch ein unglaublicher Fundus, um daraus Spiele zu machen. Was ich so eigentlich bisher noch gar nicht gesehen habe. Also das ganze Weltwissen liegt jetzt eigentlich digitalisiert herum, aber es wird halt noch überhaupt gar nicht erschlossen.
Ja also die eine Seite, das ist auch so ein bisschen ein Trend, der sich unter dem Begriff Gamification jetzt gerade tummelt, ist zu sagen, wie kriege ich es hin, sozusagen die Benutzer dazu zu „benutzen“ durch ein Spielerlebnis an Usergenerated Content zu kommen zum Beispiel. Das was du genannt hast ist ein Beispiel. Andere Beispiele gibt es ja zu Hauf. Jemand, der als Museum mit wenig Geld, seinen Fundus katalogisiert und verschlagwortet, indem er einfach ein Spiel anbietet, wo immer zwei gegeneinander spielen. Und immer wenn zwei dieselben Schlagwörter genannt haben, dann kriegt man doppelt so viele Punkte. Das ist ein super System. So was gibt es ganz viel, bis hin zu so was wie Folded, das ist ein Spiel, was mal jemand aus dem Bereich Medizinforschung im Kontext Eiweißproteinsynthese oder so was entwickelt hat, ich bin kein Mediziner, man möge mir das verzeihen.
Aber den Medizinern ist aufgefallen, dass dieses Proteinfalten eigentlich etwas ist, was man in irgendeiner Form in ein Gameplay übersetzen kann, ohne selber Experte dafür zu sein. Und tatsächlich hat das funktioniert, er hat dieses Spiel Folded irgendwie öffentlich gestellt für jeden zugänglich und hat dann solche Aufgaben rein gestellt, wie sie normalerweise eben in der Forschung vorkommt und das mit unglaublichen Ergebnissen. Also die weltweite Community hat da innerhalb von wenigen Tagen Ergebnisse hervorgebracht, die die Expertengemeinschaft nicht in 10 Jahren hinbekommen hat. Und nicht deswegen weil sie schlauer sind, sondern deswegen weil es wahnsinnig viel mehr sind und weil die Ansätze von nicht-Experten zum Teil manchmal kreativer sind als die von Experten, die vielleicht bestimmte Dinge, also betriebsblind bedingt, vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr sehen. Also was ich damit nur sagen will ist, man kann das ja durchaus so denken, dass einerseits Spielprinzipien die Welt wie sie ist ein bisschen besser machen können, aber umgekehrt, dass das was wir an Wissen haben, dann wirklich umzusetzen in wirklich nutzbares Wissen.
Zum Beispiel eben in Form eines Spiels. Da sind wir tatsächlich, das sehe ich ganz ähnlich, immer noch zu sehr am Anfang. Da könnten wir tatsächlich schon sehr viel weiter sein. Und ich glaube, dass es damit zusammenhängt, dass man Wissen immer noch für eine heilige Kuh hält, der man sich nur auf eine sehr ernsthafte und auch mit Leiden verbundene Auseinandersetzung sich wirklich aneignen kann. So dieses ganz berühmte alte Wort, Lernen muss weh tun, das haben dann ja doch sehr viele verinnerlicht. Also vor allem sehr viele Lehrende habend das verinnerlicht. Also es kann nur ernsthaftes Wissen sein, wenn man sich wirklich sehr intensiv und mit Leid und Schmerz damit beschäftigt.
Und wir sind jetzt hier eigentlich ganz woanders angekommen. Lernen muss Spaß machen, und muss eigentlich auch eine spielerische Herausforderung sein. Ich meine, umso mehr ich jetzt darüber nachdenke, wie viel ungenutztes Potenzial es da gibt. Ich meine, was weiß ich, und wenn es nur so was wie Vokabeltrainer sind. Da hat man dann so eine Maschine, die einem irgendwie was vorliest und abfragt, okay das mag schon mal ein ganz interessanter Einsatz des Computers sein, aber spielerisch ist es nicht. Und es lässt auch glaube ich diese Vernetzungsaspekte auch komplett raus. Weil ich habe selber gemerkt, dass ich eigentlich immer dann am besten Dinge lerne, in dem Moment wo ich gezwungen bin, sie jemandem zu erklären. Das hat viel besser funktioniert, also man sollte vielleicht statt sozusagen gleich mit dem Lehren anfangen und nicht erst mit dem Lernen.
Und wenn man sozusagen was weiß ich Schüler und Studenten jetzt auch weltweit miteinander vernetzt, die sozusagen komplementäre Interessen haben. Ein Deutscher möchte spanisch lernen, eine Spanierin will deutsch lernen, warum spielen die nicht zusammen ein Spiel und bringen sich sozusagen gegenseitig die eigene Sprache bei.
Ganz genau. Also der eine Punkt, den du zuerst genannt hast, mit dem Vokabeltrainer, das ist so ein Punkt, wo ich mich dann frage, ist das denn wirklich die effektivste Methode, eine Sprache zu lernen? Vokabeltraining, nein. Wir wissen ganz genau, dass es nicht so ist. Immer wenn jemand sagt, ich habe nur Schulenglisch oder Schulfranzösisch, dann ist es gleichbedeutend mit „ich habe keine Ahnung“, ich kann mir vielleicht gerade mal einen Kaffee bestellen. Und das ist das, was daran so grotesk ist. Wir wissen eigentlich, dass Sprache sprechen die beste Möglichkeit ist, Sprache zu lernen und trotzdem üben wir Vokabeln. Wobei ich nicht bestreiten will, dass Vokabeltraining sicher ganz sinnvoll sein kann ab einer bestimmten Kompetenzstufe. Aber als Beispiel dafür, vielleicht muss man einfach ganz andere Möglichkeiten finden oder vielleicht können wir jetzt auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten finden, des sich gegenseitig was Beibringens und dein Beispiel fand ich übrigens tatsächlich sehr gut, die aber erst mal voraussetzen, dass wir von so ganz klassischen Lernformaten einfach mal weggehen und einfach mal anders darüber nachdenken, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es denn?
Und dann können wir hingehen und sagen, heute ist es kein Problem mehr, wenn einer in Spanien sitzt und der andere in Deutschland oder wo auch immer. Das war sicher vor 20 Jahren eine unlösbare Aufgabe oder eine vergleichsweise unlösbare Aufgabe. Heute haben wir Onlinekurse von Stanford oder wem auch immer, da gucken 20.000 Leute zu. Die machen da nicht alle ein Zertifikat, aber was sie sich anschauen trägt ein Dozent vor, das ist der eine Punkt, aber der viel spannendere Punkt ist, was danach passiert. Nämlich wenn irgendjemand anfängt, diese Kurse zu übersetzen in alle möglichen Sprachen. Ich habe da selber einen mitgemacht, innerhalb von einer Woche gab es dort die Vorlesung, also jede Vorlesung wurde da innerhalb von einer Woche in 15-20 unterschiedliche Sprachen übersetzt mit untertiteln. Das ist das Tool, was da sozusagen mit beigegeben hat und der ganzen Diskussion, die wir eben von Wikipedia kennen. Du das hast du vielleicht noch nicht so 100% richtig übersetzt, ich mache mal den und den Vorschlag.
Und dann kommt wieder eine neue Sprache dazu und dann diskutieren alle miteinander. Und das habe ich als den eigentlichen Lerneffekt empfunden. Gar nicht unbedingt das Video, sondern diese Diskussion, die danach in der Community stattfand derer, die die Videos übersetzt haben in andere Sprachen. Und genauso hat Wikipedia ja im Grunde genommen auch ... funktioniert ja Wikipedia ja auch. Die Diskussion, um wirklich zu einem Artikel zu kommen, der eigentlich alle wichtigen Aspekte des Themas behandelt, die sind ja eigentlich das spannende. Und wie viele Menschen gibt es, die an bestimmten Wikipedia-Aspekten arbeiten. Die dann selber eine eigene Community führen, die selber dann als Redakteure eingestellt werden und so weiter. Aber letzten Endes ist es ja Crowdwissen.
Stellt sich natürlich so zum Abschluss die Frage, ob man nicht letzten Endes so ein bisschen auch an der Abschaffung des universitären Systems, wie wir es heute kennen, arbeiten müssten. Also hat sich das nicht so ein bisschen überholt?
Also gleich die Universitäten abschaffen finde ich jetzt ein bisschen radikal.
Nein, es muss sich ja nicht gleich abschaffen, wenn es sich wandelt. Also es würde sowieso nicht von heute auf morgen stattfinden und das war jetzt auch gar nicht meine Intention mit der Frage. Aber wenn man halt sieht, wie viel auf einmal geht mit dem Netz, wenn man auf einmal sieht, wie viel geht mit einer interaktiven Spielegestaltung. Indem man sozusagen sowohl die Motivation als auch den Lerneffekt als solchen ganz anders angeht. Und einfach wegkommt von dem reinen, hier ich hau es dir rein, und ich frage es in zwei Wochen ab und wenn du 5 Punkte hast, dann gilt das jetzt als erlernt. Das mag ja dann ein System sein, was eine gewisse Effizienz auch gehabt hat bis heute, weil es eben keine anderen Möglichkeiten gab. Jetzt haben wir diese anderen Möglichkeiten, jetzt haben wir interaktive Maschinen, die ein beträchtliches Wissen vorhalten können, also sehr viele Daten vorhalten können.
Wir haben genug Möglichkeiten, diese Daten in eine beliebige Kombinatorik zu bringen und eben auch in solche Spielstrategien mit einfließen zu lassen und wir haben das Internet dazu und eine generelle Vernetzung und man sieht auch, Vorlesungen naja, warum hält man die eigentlich jetzt immer wieder nochmal, wenn man sie auch einmal aufzeichnen kann, weil danach ist es ja immer noch dieselbe. Also dadurch ändert sich ja im Prinzip die ganze Hochschullandschaft langfristig ganz automatisch. Da muss man doch jetzt auch schon drüber nachdenken, was so die Antworten von übermorgen sind.
Ja das ist absolut richtig. Also das sehe ich ganz genauso. Was wir auf jeden Fall erst mal überdenken sollten, um da einen Ansatz zu finden, ist denn wirklich jede Fachrichtung und jeder Beruf, der daraus resultiert, hat andere Anforderungen. Aber ich glaube wir sollten viel mehr thematisieren, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Lernen und Lernabfrage. Ich habe oft das Gefühl, dass die meisten unter Lernen verstehen, dass sie am Schluss irgendeine Frage richtig oder falsch beantworten können, also die Abfrage. Das ist das was bewertbar ist. Das ist auch immer das Argument, wir müssen es ja bewerten. Das ist das universitäre System, in dem muss alles bewertet werden oder nahezu alles bewertet werden in irgendeiner Form. Da kommen wir auch nicht dran vorbei, das ist wenn man so will ja auch eine Form von Vorschrift, ohne das jetzt weiter erläutern zu wollen, aber das heißt wir können die Leute nicht einfach nicht benoten. Und die Frage wäre auch, ist das überhaupt sinnvoll.
Die Frage ist, wer gibt die Note? Und geben sie sich selber, indem sie ein bestimmtes Aufgabenfeld bearbeiten und es erfolgreich ist und damit ergibt sich die Note auch selber, weil das wäre ja theoretisch jetzt schon möglich. Dann der zweite Aspekt ist der, nochmal viel deutlicher sich klarzumachen, wie schaffen wir das, dass wir Lernprozesse also wirklich effektiv und effizient, also sprich nachhaltig machen. Also nachhaltig da gibt es mehrere Komponenten, ja es muss Spaß machen, es muss in irgendeinem Kontext stehen, ich habe da was gebaut und es funktioniert. Dann ist es sehr viel nachhaltiger, als wenn ich das einfach nur in der Theorie gelöst habe usw. Es gibt da also viele Kennzeichen dafür, wie man sagen wir mal das reine Lernen deutlich verbessern kann. Und ein Punkt ist eben der, dass man sagt, die Abfrage steht auf dem zweiten Blatt. Weil wenn man diese Klausuren, die meisten Klausuren, wenn man die nach einem halben Jahr nochmal schreiben würde ohne Ankündigung, dann würde aus einer 1 oder einer 2 auch ganz schnell eine 5 werden.
Weil man eben ganz viel wieder vergisst. Das wissen im Grunde genommen auch alle Lehrenden, aber man nimmt es eben so hin, als so eine Lernkonvention. Und wenn man sich viel mehr darauf konzentrierten müssten, was müssen wir für Kompetenzen haben in den nächsten 2, 3, 4 Jahren und darüber hinaus in einer auch von mir aus als moderne Mediengesellschaft bezeichneten Welt, wo wir alle miteinander vernetzt sind, wollen wir nicht besser Werkzeuge schaffen, im Grunde genommen das was du vorgeschlagen hast, um Menschen die Möglichkeit zu geben, voneinander mehr zu lernen? Und die einfach nur besser miteinander zu verknüpfen. Und damit im Grunde genommen viel besser vorbereitet zu sein, auf das was dann auf uns zukommen wird, wenn wir Bildung als – und das tue ich tatsächlich – Bildung als eins der wichtigsten Güter, die wir als Menschen haben zu betrachten.
Bildung, Aufklärung, das ist eigentlich das was wir als Ressourcen haben. Eine der wichtigsten Ressourcen glaube ich, die wir haben. Und die kriegen wir nicht dadurch, dass wir Menschen beibringen, dass ihr hinterher irgendein Haken sagt, richtig oder falsch, wie bei einer Matheaufgabe, da mag es noch stimmen. Aber in den Herausforderungen, die noch gesellschaftlich auf uns zukommen werden, globalgesellschaftlich auf uns zukommen werden, wird das nicht mehr reichen.
Ja von der Zensur zu den Experience Points, das scheint so ein bisschen der Weg zu sein, auf den sich das alles gemacht hat.
Genau, die Experience Points, die vergeben aber im Prinzip die Lernenden demnächst selber, indem sie sie tatsächlich einfach machen.
Linda Breitlauch vielen Dank.
Für die Ausführungen. Und ja vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Wir machen wie immer bald wieder weiter. Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.
Ich danke dir.